[Music]
foreign
hey everybody what's going on oh man
look I forgot the lights you forgot to
turn the lights on yeah
he's over there in the dark yeah I
couldn't remember like which ones you
put on and which ones you did because I
don't [__] with them
I just got home that seems that seems
good that seems good yeah
yeah okay all right yeah it took a
second for it to adjust yeah yeah that's
what it does that looks a lot better
actually I thought it was a little dark
in here yeah it was
so uh Hey as as you can probably hear
Tom is a little sick yeah I got a damn
cold my [__] head's all stuffed up he
even sleeping all day all day I have a
little bit of a cold too but I had to go
to work so yeah and I got damn it's not
Rag and [__] so you just hear me bucket
blowing blow my [__] brains out
so sure everybody else you can say it's
like werewolf noises yeah that's what
you say I got I want all kinds of
medicine it's not helping hopefully this
booze will help
boots usually helps me honestly more
than cold medicine I don't get colds a
lot like I have one and I feel kind of
crappy but not
that bad but all of a good day I know I
was kind of getting worried about you
because he doesn't usually like go all
day without messaging me and I'm like
man he's either asleep or he's dead
what's funny is I woke up at like
four o'clock in the morning
um last night and uh I I thought I was
awake and I rolled over you weren't in
bed it was about two two hours had
passed you'd already gone to work I
didn't hear you get up or anything
I must fall back asleep I got up a
little before I thought I was there
before five like usual I did get up at
um
like one or two to go to the bathroom
which I usually do yeah and I thought I
heard
Dakota like being like yeah where is
everybody yeah what's that kind of thing
she's uh racing up and down the stairs
now that's her new day yeah and the Two
Kitties they're still kind of um
unsure about they're not beating each
other up or anything but they'll kind of
come and like look at each other like
What's your deal they're gonna start
getting along I think they will yeah
Esther said Jenny you look great thank
you very much slasher friend said this
sure is a first time first time you're
talking about lores about supernatural
creatures I mean usually you talk about
true stories yeah
um no we've done like a we did a Cryptid
show but that was like a long time ago
we talked about depth sea monsters and
everything yeah oh yeah that's right
that was really old yeah we did like a
sea monster show yeah and the thing
about it is that we've done like vampire
adjacent topics like we did a show about
Vlad the Impaler we did a show about uh
Elizabeth Bathory we did a show about
um Mercy Brown uh who is a real person
that they thought was a vampire because
we'll get into that a little bit so I
might not bring that stuff up as much
because
we've already done shows about that but
and the thing about it is that Vlad the
Impaler even though he comes up a lot
like on vampire topics he really only
comes up because of
him's like sort of being based on
Dracula sort of being based on him so
it's like nobody thought that Vlad the
Impaler was a vampire
in his lifetime nobody called him that
well
propaganda at the time said he was
drinking blood yeah he was doing a bunch
of other [__] too
but you know he's he's a hero Romanian
hero well yeah and I was just like
watching a documentary earlier that said
that and I might have mentioned in this
this on the Vlad the Impaler show is
that in Romania they actually wouldn't
allow Dracula to be published for like a
very very long time because it pissed
him off a little bit yeah because he
just defend he was defended Romania from
like the Turkish Empire it was during
the time where the ottoman Turks were
trying to invade and everything
had uh he lived in a place he he
basically was in charge of a little
kingdom called velocia that's what it
was called back then nowadays it's
Transylvania but it's not quite the same
borders
and the church he fought for the church
church told him to keep to keep the
Islamic Invasion out
and uh
with extreme prejudice back and forth
between the Daybreak families boyars who
were some kind of Saxon Merchants were
[__] with them because they were I
think they wanted the I think they
wanted to align with the Turks actually
and he used a basically a campaign of
Terror to unify volakia and to get
foreigners out uh
uh so part of the things you do is to
the pale people which is impaled it's a
fantastic punishment
it takes a long time and it it leaves a
monument of your makes your victim into
a monument and other attackers come and
see him go down that's [__] up yeah
who could this this is a bad dude it's
Terror and horror campaigns are work
they work just ask the Mexican Mafia
you know [__] their court systems
their judges are terrified of them
because they'll come after you and your
kids and everything they just
infiltrated your systems you can't get
away from us you know
but that's that's what that's what uh
Vlad was all about he was using
bafia Horror Attack techniques they work
though
Juan says hello Tom and Jenny how are
you we're good there Tom is kind of sick
I'm slightly sick but I never get as
sick as he does because my immune system
is almost impenetrable at least so far
she doesn't respond to anything she
should be respond to Medicine hardly no
well in a way that's kind of a blessing
and a curse because it's like sometimes
if I actually do get kind of sick and I
take medicine it doesn't dejections yeah
so you just have to kind of ride it out
it's a real thing it's called a weak
responder but luckily I don't usually
non-responder she's gonna go years and
years without getting cold she's what
they call it in in the gym business a
weak responder
which sounds negative when you put it
like that there's a weak response to
everything you do yeah you don't get
sick you get sick it's a weak response
give them medicine it's a weak response
yeah yeah
but you know
I'll take it it's you know I'd rather
have that than like just get sick of the
drop of a hat that's for sure yeah
one said the setup looks cool okay so
they must not have been here well no
it's not like a while I think we've had
it for like a week right yeah didn't we
rearrange it like last weekend or no not
last week in the weekend yeah I wanted
to do it like this for a long time Jenny
wasn't having it we eventually got
around doing it well because I knew it
was going to be a pain in the ass
it wasn't really it was kind of a pain
in the ass but uh but yeah well I was
gonna I was to say it was gonna be a
pain in the ass because initially you
said that we had to move this desk too
and I was like oh no I don't want to
[__] do that because then I have to
take all his books down and all that
other kind of crap that's what I was
thinking no I was just I just moved to
that desk over here okay well yeah but
before you said we had to move all of it
and I was just like I don't want to do
that
uh John Robertson today guys I watched
Dracula 2020 TV series and the third
episode is in the modern day Dracula
loves Modern Day stuff and Tom's ideas
of Dracula and the modern day is pretty
much that episode I think we watched
that was that the one that was like
wasn't it like a mini series like three
episodes I want to say it was a while
back that we saw it but yeah like the
first two were in yeah but then like the
third one wasn't the president I
remember kind of liking it I don't
remember what my ideas were either about
Dracula in the modern day
well yeah I'll just do that Dracula
would be into technology
yeah he would like the modern world
yeah well I guess I guess the I don't
know like I guess more the movie
character than the book character Maybe
although maybe not
Maybe not maybe not directly be it to
the internet he'd like internet porn
he'd like everybody
are you sure you're not saying that
because you like internet porn
this is high tech right he ought to have
his own version of it right it'd be like
[__] cam to cam blood drinking and
[__]
you know I'm sure that there's well
there I'm sure there's niches for that
yeah because there is a whole little
vampire
subculture which yeah they'd be doing
that can get a little weird to be honest
with you some people like take it
entirely too seriously oh and that's
another thing too is that we all we've
also done shows about quote unquote
Vampire Killers Like Richard Chase and
uh that other [__] from Eustace
from here actually yeah Will Ferrell no
rodford Rod Farrell Will Ferrell is the
guy yeah
yeah I worked for his uh
his for initial attorney
I saw it I saw his case File when he
first got arrested I ended up filing it
when I was doing law clerk worked for
her
but she passed him on to another one so
she didn't have it for very long but uh
yeah Pharaoh I had forgotten all about
he's not from here originally like he
moved here later but I had forgotten
that he did live here in Houston that's
where we live right now because I was
listening to something about him the
other day and I was just like oh yeah
that's right it's a real fantasy Pro
Golf kid
yeah and like I said there there are
like a small it's a small minority you
don't see as much I feel like the big
Heyday of that was like the 90s when
vampire the Masquerade came out like
everybody was going around calling
themselves like all these fancy vampires
vampire names it was large what was his
he was the Sago wasn't he yeah the Sago
yeah which that sounds like a Yamaha
motorcycle it does kind of I got a 750
for Sago oh yeah
either that or it sounds like an exotic
spice you know what I mean it's in like
Malaysian Cuisine or something I don't
know but it doesn't sound like a vampire
name
hahaha
uh yeah John says Dracula upgraded his
fashion he used a phone and iPad and he
thought a dump of a house was a palace
and he absolutely loved it yeah yeah I
remember we did watch that we did watch
it I don't remember that one we could
probably rewatch it I think it was only
three episodes like it was a mini series
type of thing I remember it I remember
liking it we might have reviewed it too
now that I'm thinking about it get a
dump of the house you thought it was a
castle
well yeah well he thought it was like
super cool because like obviously all
the modern convenience oh it could be
like a big deal you know right yeah
because he's like oh I was like well
like I said it's if you took like a
medieval peasant yeah then brought them
to like a trailer park nowadays they'd
probably think it was the most
miraculous thing yeah
Mark says anybody remember when Leslie
Nielsen played Dracula he was didn't he
do um Dracula dead and Loving It it's
called Love Bites or is that it wasn't
no no that was um Love At First Bite
that was George Hamilton I remember that
one too I remember really liking that
movie but um I bet it didn't age very
well yeah no no Leslie Nielsen I'm
pretty sure wasn't Dracula dead and
Loving It which was also uh comedy that
wasn't Mel Brooks was it
I can't remember if it was Mel Brooks or
not
but yeah so like I said this will
probably be
um let's just talk about vampire lord
vampire movies whatever you were in
werewolf stuff too like whatever you
guys like feel like wanted to talk about
I've watched like a bunch of different
stuff and there's just there's so much
stuff that it's like hard to distill it
down into one
thing so this might be kind of all over
the place but you know what I mean yes
it was Mel Brooks okay so my memories
like a lot better than I thought it was
um Fred said if you ever see son of
Dracula with Lon Chaney Jr his character
name is Alucard yeah I kind of feel like
they started doing that a lot like in
the vampires they were like we're gonna
be super sneaky it's not a Dracula movie
it's Alucard even though you know
obviously that's like Dracula's Bell
backwards I think they did that in some
of the hammer films too
but yeah well then think about the
vampire movies well as far as like
vampire lore goes is that are you
breathing over there yeah oh okay I
can't breathe okay it's like I just I
heard that noise and I was like what is
that
but the thing about
um
vampire lore is that a lot of the
vampire lore that people know nowadays
is actually quite recent
and a lot of it comes from Dracula from
the novel from 1897. or from like some
[__] before that because Dracula wasn't
the first vampire thing there was also
uh there was one just called The Vampire
which was written by John polidori even
though when it came out it was actually
attributed to Lord Byron
but it was actually
um his personal physician Dr John
polidori who wrote it and the character
of Lord Ruthven in the vampire with a y
is thought to be the first
aristocratic vampire and it was because
polidori based it on Lord Byron lace the
base the character on Lord Byron prior
to that
I mean as far as I'm aware that was the
first
large-scale fictional story that had
like a cultural impact that had a
vampire that was an aristocrat you know
what I mean so Dracula wasn't the first
one to do that I think the vampire was
the first to do that and because prior
to that like I said the vampire just
been like a monster it was just
essentially like a ghoul yeah like not
quite like a zombie but kinda
and vampires were actually considered
like gross
pretty gross they don't look anything
like
what we would conceive of as a vampire
nowadays I did like that Anne Rice which
um I can't remember what bucket was but
where she
wasn't it when Lestat was like looking
for
these other vampires and he found those
ones that just like lived in the
cemeteries and were all like gross and
nasty and
it was a French Cemetery yeah yeah they
were grossed they were regular they were
kids like regular people he fed
if vampireless stop
when he was young
this is still back like I guess like in
the
1600s
he found
a vampire walking through the forest
that he had that was like a wild animal
a lot more like a living corpse he
destroyed it from what I remember and he
didn't know what it was never saw
another one
yeah that's right yeah but that's kind
of to me is like what I conceive of when
you talk about like folkloric vampires
yeah
so everything
destroyed it
let's stop fans probably would but for
whatever and he just fetches it very
briefly
that you know when he was looking for
other vampires he when he was in his uh
Fortress
he uh heard it thinking he heard His
Thoughts From a long distance away and
he flew out there right out there on a
river I don't know I think he could fly
by that point could he
but he went down there and uh
saw what it was and he just said it was
it was a vampire it was like a living
corpse it was just uh
horrid so he just I think he destroyed
it
it was Mindless
yeah and for
probably hundreds or thousands of years
that was actually the folkloric vampire
that's what people were talking about
when they talked about vampires they
weren't talking about like some Suave
[__] with fangs and all that
kind of stuff that
they're talking about a ghoul yeah
essentially or a zombie yeah it was
almost more like a zombie really yeah
and the thing about it was that they
didn't look anything like because I kind
of feel like nowadays people have a
perception of vampires being like really
gaunt and pale
and you know like I said kind of suave
and everything like that but like back
in the day
vampires looked more like
bloated corpses yeah because they were
supposedly like engorged with blood so
almost like a tick because that's what
they did they went around and like fed
on people so they looked also their skin
looked all dark like it was decomposed
kind of like purple
it's because they were digging people up
suspected they were vampires when you
dig up a body they're bloated
yes and well and that's what and I think
that I think a lot of the um scholarship
around where a lot of these uh Legends
came from
and I think kind of the overarching idea
is that well you know back in the day
people didn't really
understand bodily composition like
decomposition all that well so it's like
if they happen to
and it would happen was like a small
village it's like a bunch of people
suddenly died of some disease and they
didn't know what it was and so they
would immediately suspect oh well that
person that recently died is getting up
out of their graves and they're killing
everybody like in this one family
because usually vampirism it was usually
like a relative like the relative would
get up and like come back and eat their
family first and then move on to like
the rest of the townsfolk so they would
be like well that you know Jim that guy
that just died he's a vampire so we need
to go check that [__] out so then they
would go and dig him up and because they
didn't see I guess a lot of dead bodies
in that particular
context
um if you opened the coffin and the body
was all bloated from you know gases and
stuff like that and sometimes like you
know the lungs will push blood out of
the mouth so sometimes it had like they
had blood all over their face [__] like
that and they would think oh well this
is obviously the problem
they would drive a steak through their
heart or whatever cut their head off
remember when I was a kid I'd read books
about this kind of stuff they would have
oh like excerpts from weaknesses of the
times when they dig it up they would say
well this has to be a vampire because
this person was buried 18 months ago and
look how fresh they are yeah
but they didn't know about decomposition
they had no idea what Refrigeration was
like yeah
they were in places of Europe where they
buried pretty deep
and there were there were places where
you know the crowd never really got that
warm so it might have been you know 40
degrees 40 degrees 50 degrees
Fahrenheit in the suburb you know in
[__] Sub-Zero it might have been
frozen during the winter yeah so you
know yeah it could 18 bucks it'd still
be together it'd be wrong but
you'd still it would be boats though you
know that's what they're like yeah it
would still look like still look like
pretty good for a dead body
for 18 months you know still look pretty
good
and here's something that I never I
don't know if I ever made this exact
Association but you know how there's a
thing where vampires like you're
supposed to kill them with a stake
through the heart and all this other
kind of [__]
um which it's not always stake through
the heart sometimes it sticks through
the mouth like depending on what part of
the world you're talking about
and for some reason like I was like well
that seems kind of random but and it's
just seems kind of random because we'll
stake through the heart will kill
anybody not just a vampire right but the
thing about it where they think that
came from is because they would stake
corpses they would pin them in the
coffin so they couldn't get out yeah
they're Dale to the coffee like so
they're nailed in there so that's kind
of where the whole thing about Stakes
being able to kill them because that's
what they use they sharpen sticks and
we're like this [__] is not
getting us they bury him upside down
yeah they did that too Earth instead of
digging it they did that too yeah and
they would leave stuff this is one of
the funniest things they would leave
stuff like by the grave sometimes like
sickles or things because apparently
that was something they liked or that
would keep them in their graves or
whatever
um sometimes they would put like little
things of Jesus and stuff and sometimes
and this wasn't just for vampires this
was for other supernatural creatures as
well but sometimes they would put stuff
like
um grains of rice that was Asia mostly
or like little millet seeds or they
would have like a net that had like
thousands of knots tied in it because
for whatever reason and I don't know
what the origin of this belief is but
apparently vampires as well as some
other supernatural creatures if they see
[__] like that like just like a bunch of
sand or something they have to stop and
count every single grain of it like and
like I said and I haven't I've heard
that about witches too I don't think
that's Universal but but I've heard
about other supernatural creatures and I
don't really know what the origin of
that is where it's like they wake up and
they're just like ah there's like all
this sand there they're just like oh
it's one two three and then the sun
comes up and they die oh that's another
thing too is that
and this was even and this just goes to
show how
I don't know like how the folklore has
like really changed over the years and
you know been informed by popular
culture is that really
um even in Dracula which you know was
like I said not the first vampire you
had the vampire by John polidori before
that and then you had um carmilla like
after that was 18 19 I want to say 1817
somewhere around there so it was a while
maybe it was later maybe it's 1872. but
um but that was like a while before uh
Dracula thank you very much Titanic
discussions that's a very nice Super
Chat hello I want to say recently
discovered your channel and really enjoy
your reviews also how uh shout out to
return to Living Dead which debuted 38
years ago tonight I saw the 7 30 show
enjoy a pizza my treat and thanks thank
you very much that's very very nice of
you
time I'll be back in a minute he's
blowing it he has a really bad cold and
I was like he's been sleeping all day
and I came down I'm like are you gonna
be able to do the shower should we push
it back to tomorrow or are you gonna be
all right but yeah what we're talking
about people behind my back yeah I'm
talking about you behind your back time
yeah he sucks I would never say that I
mean I just said it to your face but I
did it miserable I know you are but yeah
we got we got a really nice uh Super
Chat from a new fan that just discovered
our show just discovered our reviews and
stuff like that too discussions yeah
yeah thank you man yeah that's awesome I
said have a pizza on them
which we just may or some Chinese food
or something
um but yeah so the whole thing about
vampires getting killed in sunlight
which actually they even did in um the
new movie that just that we just saw
that we just reviewed last Voyage of the
Demeter that one like as soon as the sun
like touched the vampire they were like
then they just like went up in Flames
um that's a very recent
uh Edition that might have been from I
think the first time that Trope appeared
was actually in nosferato because that's
not even in the book Dracula in the book
could move around in the daytime like he
wouldn't burn up in the sun he wasn't as
strong like he would like it
significantly weakened his powers and
[__] like that but he could walk around
in the day it was all right yeah he
wouldn't die so I think Nosferatu from
1922 was the first one to actually have
you know where Max Shrek was there in
front of the window and like the sun
comes in and he's like oh no and he just
like Fades away but I think that was the
first time to happen
somebody brought up earlier like um not
being able to see their Reflections in
mirrors
I'm not sure I think that might have
been
um
that either came from Dracula or is not
that much older than Dracula
and
I think that too if if Dracula was the
first time that that appeared
that's probably part of folklore again
not just vampires but any kind of
Supernatural creature because they're
considered I think the the
the story is that because they're
considered soulless
that they don't appear in mirrors that's
what I always heard like the mirror just
reflects your soul right right but yeah
so so I don't think that's super old
background they all have souls
yeah see so everything that is in a
mirror like yeah implicitly has a soul
yeah see that's a good point that you're
making you're right
animals have souls because animals
appear in mirrors also I believe animals
have souls anyway
well I don't believe anybody has souls
but I know but I but I'm a big advocate
of animals being um not different from
humans really the soul what they're
talking about with the soul is they're
talking about what what haveroff is
calling but Stuart haveroff is called
the the quantum consciousness
that's it it's a it's a it's a field of
super Tangled particles
yeah it's what gives you koalia
the the sense of being
you know with that you could
you know what the taste of coffee is
where you know what things feel like
if you were just cop Computing like a
like a like a computer you wouldn't have
a Consciousness or an equalia
cheddy's bit of that statement and it
hasn't really quite clicked with her
that that's the quality exists
when she came out of surgery and she was
uh
still under the effects of anesthesia I
talked to her for about an hour she
doesn't remember a bit of it
because she was a conscious there at
that time
well that's happened to me like when I
was like sleeping and stuff too and like
like I've been sleeping and like my
grandma or something like woke me up and
then she said oh you said this that and
the other thing yeah I don't remember
any of that yeah
because because your Consciousness was
turned off right
[Music]
yeah
so my head's gonna blow up well oh my
God so it might go like scanners right
here on this very show I feel all this
pressure up my head's gonna blow up
slasher friend said do you consider
Voyage of the demeanor to be a Dracula
spin-off it's not a spin-off it's an
adaptation of part of the book yeah yeah
chapter seven to be specific
um the Captain's Log so it's right there
and they yeah and they didn't really I
mean they took some creative Liberties
but not a lot I mean they did flesh it
out some everything's plausible but it's
pretty faithful to the chapter it's not
a long chapter it's only like three or
four pages but I don't know I really
liked that movie I know it hasn't been
getting like super great reviews like or
like mixed reviews like it's getting
kind of half and half but I thought it
was great people got bad taste I really
really liked it they got bad taste [__]
what they say that's a good movie yeah I
really liked it like I said it was it
was cool I hope they tell the rest of
the story but I don't think they will
they probably won't because it's not
doing very well well they put so much
money in these things they expected to
make a billion bucks out of each one of
them movies aren't what they were you
know
that's competing against a lot of other
[__]
movies are becoming like
they're going to go out of style you
know video games are better
eventually movies won't be kind of like
what we consider an epic poem would you
go do you go listen to poetry readings
with that epic poems I mean some people
no
some people might but you know it's not
a billion dollar industry that's what
movies are going to be
they're gonna take AI
we had all this [__] Graphics imagery
capabilities and they're going to put
that into a dab
program and you'll have 10 year old boys
making full length feature films just
based upon specifications they talked
about with the dev AI computer and you
would it would probably be a fantastic
movie but he's done with it well you
know eventually you know AI at this
point can write a novel yeah it's not a
good novel you still need a person to
like look at it because it's not smart
enough to do that yeah like to
especially like longer works that kind
of like starts breaking down eventually
you can't keep track of everything
eventually that computer will be able to
to cast it with realistic it look like
they're real people you can even say I
want Humphrey Bogart to be the main
character and it and it'll [__] make
it it'll make you ball free Bogart voice
at everything
so you'll have some 10 year old boy out
what a book about a movie about Boba
Fett it's gonna do this and that it's on
this planet and then he's he watches it
and he goes no it's not quite good
change it here here and here and and
before you know it he's [__] made a
badass movie
Hollywood won't be able to compete with
that
but the thing is is that the the value
of movies will plummet because anybody
will be able to do it
you're probably gonna see it for free
and they're just AI
Ben said I think when Dracula walked
around during the day he was
comparatively weak yeah he was like his
powers were notably diminished but the
sun didn't kill him I like I said I'm
pretty sure and please correct me if I'm
wrong but I'm pretty sure that FW
murnau's nosferati was the first one
that the sun like straight up killed him
like as soon as it hit him and then from
then on
it seemed to although I will note I
didn't really want to bring up twilight
but we had to bring up twice I heard
it's good what Twilight I heard it's
good you know it's awful is it terrible
the books are awful okay the books are
awful and the movies are awful
um but they were popular though
um yeah it was it was a teen girl
phenomenon yeah
um but I've read some of the books and
it's like they're awful
um but
well isn't like Edward Cullen in that he
could he can go out in the daytime right
he's just he just Sparkles that's like
the joke about it he just sparkles in
the daytime but he can't go out in the
daytime
so they kind of went back to the old
school on that one slasher Fred said
there was a movie called Dracula Untold
yeah we saw that we were we reviewed
that I got it a while back I really
liked that yeah
I really liked it uh and then manga says
the last Voyage can only be seen in the
USA it was pulled for the rest of the
world
that's dumb no why would it be
that is that's dumb if they did that I
didn't hear that I mean I feel like it
might if they really did do that I feel
like it would be maybe even do better in
other countries
because it's kind of like an old school
Gothic movie and maybe like people in
other countries was like that better
than Americans maybe I don't know hi
Pokey
oh yeah only thing I heard that got
pulled lately was Barbie got pulled in
several countries
that's it that's the only thing I heard
about recently
Joseph said the thing bombed when it
first came out now it's a classic will
Demeter have the same fate
see I'm not really sure it's hard to
tell
um yeah there was a lot of movies that
famously well [__] I mean even not only
the thing but The Shining when The
Shining came out I believe it got
nominated for a Razzie award which is
crazy
um and that's like one of the best
movies ever and same thing with the
thing it's just like I don't know if the
thing got like got super shitty reviews
it's just like nobody was real into it
it did get some shitty reviews I think
but people didn't really recognize and
that happens a lot but then it then I
mean a movie might come out and you know
people are like eh and then like 20
years later you see it and you're like
yeah I get it I get why nobody likes
this [__] you know what I mean so it's
kind of hard to tell I mean I really
liked this movie
but
you know everyone's opinion is different
I don't know
Ben said not putting Dracula in the
title cost him a billion dollars ins
well that's the thing like in some
territories
I think it was called Dracula Voyage of
the demeanor
but maybe they thought calling it
Dracula over here everybody would be
like not Dracula again Jesus Christ you
know maybe that's what I was thinking
because I was thinking to myself I mean
I immediately knew what last Voyage of
the Demeter was because I've read
Dracula and I thought you know most
people were at least familiar enough
with the lore or at least see it enough
Dracula movies to know what that was but
I guess not because I said something
about it at work and they didn't know
what that was yeah I was like you know
like from Dracula the boat
she's always projecting her IQ
well it's hard it's hard it's difficult
for me well it's not so much smarts it's
that
um you know I do realize that I'm uh
into you know I'm really into horror
[__] I'm really into like horror movies
and I'm really into horror books and I
know a lot about it I know a lot about
the history of it so I always have to
like
temper my enthusiasm when I'm around
other people because I'll go off on
those big tangents and they won't know
what the [__] they were talking about
and it's like and then and then I get
really like frustrated because then I
have to go back and explain everything
and I hate having to do that you know
what I mean
so it's just I'm like give it to program
get with the program you know what I
mean but it's that kind of yeah of
course it is an interesting video this
huh the average person is I know and
then like I said that's why I always
found that like really really
frustrating you could probably go to
your average 17 year old and ask them
about Dracula they wouldn't really know
anything about the original story yeah
maybe not they would know nothing about
that maybe not Dracula what's that you
know
although I will say I think Dracula at
least has penetrated the cultural
Zeitgeist to such a degree that
everybody I think and I'm not sure again
I'm not sure if this but I read this
somewhere I think that Dracula is the
second most
featured character like fictional
character in filmdom ever do you know
who the first one is
Sherlock Holmes Sherlock Holmes is the
first one but um but I'm pretty sure
Dracula's second that's so they've made
like a [__] ton of Dracula movies or
movies that have Dracula in them because
I think that also counts like any time
that he comes out like in a movie
but um
slasher friend said there was an episode
of Buffy the Vampire Slayer where Buffy
fought against Dracula yeah it comes I
did I never like watched that show real
consistently but I always like liked
what I saw of it and I do kind of
remember that one
um
yeah Dracula became a recurring
character
Leslie said the movie Pacific Heights
1990 is a Dracula movie too I imagine
too I imagine [__] I haven't seen that
in a long time no I don't remember
uh there was also the Dracula 1979 movie
with doll Pleasants and frankly Angela
yeah um I actually really like that we
were talking about that one just the
other day when we were talking about
last Voyage of the Demeter because I was
wondering I actually really like that
movie I have it and I've seen it many
many times
um but I always wondered about the weird
thing where they switched Mina and Lucy
and that's not the only Dracula
adaptation to do that and I'm just like
mystified as to why they felt the need
because it really didn't seem to it
didn't add the story it didn't take away
from the story I'm not really sure so
I'm not really sure like why why they
did that but you know what I mean
um Mr 88 says tangentially related uh
Criterion just announced a Todd Browning
box set nice uh including the unknowns
during Lon Chaney this has been on my
want list in the early 2000s but never
been available on any home media yeah
[__] man that's like really really hard
to get hold of I'm gonna have to look
into that man I'm gonna have to get
really late I really
Ben says really I saw a preview
screening here but as far as I know it's
in Australian Cinema's title is Voyage
of the Demeter I'm not really sure where
I just read that it was called Dracula
Voyage of the Demeter like in some
territories but
because I guess like I said they assumed
that everybody
in English-speaking countries would know
what the Demeter was but like I said
maybe they're overestimating people's
intelligence or or cultural
um knowledge perhaps because maybe some
people did it but like I said it's hard
for me to judge because
I've grown up with this [__] my whole
life like like I said I love scary [__]
I love horror [__] and I have since I
can remember like since I can since I
could talk so Mike so my life is like so
steeped in it that it's like really hard
it's really hard just people to talk to
people that aren't like into it the same
way that I am you know what I mean
because then you have to like explain
everything
and I and I find that really frustrating
so so there's that
I mean but yeah I the the Dracula
adaptation that I had when I was a
little kid before I was old enough to
read the actual novel
was really cool they used to have these
little
um this cover was kind of like pink and
it was like a comic book but it was like
a comic book
um like Cliff it wasn't Cliff Notes but
it was like a shorter version of it but
the drawings of it were really cool I
would still remember having them but
yeah so
so like I said they're now prior to
what we would consider
vampires and this was even before the
ghoul [__] camera because I feel like
that was kind of more like a Middle Ages
type situation prior to that you had I
guess what we could call kind of like
Proto vampire sort of creatures like
there was even some like Egyptian
goddesses and stuff that drank blood and
crap like that but you also had like
Mesopotamia you know the ancient Romans
ancient Greek stuff like that they had
mostly back then and you would kind of
consider this a vampire nowadays but
they were mostly like
like Spirits essentially or demons that
um that kind of drank blood or that you
know were kind of like possessing
people's bodies and like made the bodies
get up so it was kind of more like well
didn't Anne Rice kind of went in that
direction too like when she was talking
about
um
kind of the origins of the vampires and
wasn't it the first been a while since
I've read them but um wasn't it like a
like a ghost or a demon or something
like that like a poltergeist yeah that
like inhabited there's a poltergeist
that got into it got into a damn pharaoh
yeah that's right that's right right
well I think I think it uh yeah it got
it to us
Pharaoh saw Poltergeist
he said it's some investigators to try
to figure figure out what it was
power another
a murder happens he got killed
and it went into and the Poltergeist
went into his blood
and he came back yeah I think it was
something like like I said it's been a
while since I've read the vampire
Chronicles I didn't read them all but it
killed his wife yeah turned her into a
into a poltergeist also
a vampire
was a poltergeist
possessing a person basically
it was spread throughout the blood and
then as as
uh as it spread out throughout vampires
it got weaker and weaker
so vampires have bore the power of this
thing this Poltergeist it was a it was a
bloodlusting poltergeist yeah
so let's watch to the Poltergeist it was
it was it was very simple yeah it did
have a whole lot of Tails so that's kind
of hard which is kind of why I liked
that concept because she was kind of
hearkening back to like the really
ancient
um ideas about what we would now
consider vampires where it's not like it
wasn't even back then it wasn't even
like a ghoul or anything it was like
still a Revenant I guess like as in
somebody that was dead that got up and
walked around but it was usually because
that person was kind of like
possessed by a blood drinking demon or
and it could happen too and the whole
stuff about like a vampires to bite the
another vampire and then that turns into
that was a later addition as well
um mostly it was if you were a witch or
if you committed suicide or something
like that and you died like you would
come back as this Blood drinking
Revenant type of thing so and I think
the same kind of thing happened with
werewolves as well like it didn't the
the stuff about getting bit by a
werewolf turned you into a werewolf that
was also a later invention that might
not have even come about until the
movies like The Universal movies
werewolves are Robin
the oldest story I I could that I
remembered was formation Roe there was
an older one than that there was one
from the Epic of Gilgamesh okay there's
a a reference to something that would be
considered a werewolf what is what I do
about was it was Robin yeah it was a
robot army story
something from about aerobic Legions
the a guard got attacked by a wolf he
cut his arm off
it got away
and then later one of their bids showed
up in the infirmary with his arm visit
yeah
that's a pretty common yeah and that's
there are stories like that about
witches too because I remember reading
one when I was a kid that was called
sopdoll
which was like an old like folkloric
type of tale and that was actually like
a witch but she turned into a big cat
and like so the cat got its paw cut off
but then the guy came back to the house
and then his wife didn't have a hand so
that's so that's a very common Trope
like in mythology yeah and there are a
lot of werewolf stories like the Romans
had it yeah and I think that was uh
I think Sebastian did one of the Roman
history books about a bit of soitodious
I think that's where that comes from
I I don't remember
who was the uh
the robot scientist that saw the that
got killed during the [__] eruption
about Vesuvius
was his Dave I think he looked into that
that he if I remember correctly he
thought that baby something like that
existed
what's that guy's name
uh Pliny plighty the Elder
I think plighty the Elder looked into
that I think that's where that story
came from why did the Elder knew about
that story
about the Roman army guy
I think he thought it maybe existed but
they didn't know they didn't know yeah
slasher Fred said I wonder if the lore
that a vampire could change into a wolf
or bat came from Dracula
um as far as I know yes uh that was not
and interestingly after Dracula came out
that also informed a lot of werewolf
Legends going forward
um specifically stuff about uh the
werewolves being like a man wolf rather
than just because I kind of feel like
most of the werewolves going back to
ancient times were
not necessarily like a half man half
wolf hybrid like you would see nowadays
but it was just literally a person
turning into a wolf now usually it was a
big ass wolf and it was like a little
bit different but it wasn't like
nowadays like these big like muscular
like or wolves on two legs like things
like dog soldiers or something like that
it was more like just somebody turning
into a wolf that was very common in the
Roman story it was just a wolf yeah
and like I said you could tell that it
wasn't a regular wolf but it mostly just
looked like a regular wolf
like I think sometimes they said it was
like bigger or meaner like more vicious
or whatever so you could tell that it
wasn't the same
but and the thing about vampires turning
into bats I'm pretty sure that came
directly from the book and I'm not
entirely sure
I think where where stoker got that idea
was because because vampire bats
they're only called that because of
Dracula you know what I mean like they
they weren't called vampire bats
beforehand and stoker was like oh I'll
just you know put those two things
together what happened was those that
particular species of bat is not
indigenous to Europe or a lot of the
Vampire Legends came from they're
actually indigenous too with South
America or like you know the new world
and they had just been discovered right
around the time that stoker was writing
Dracula as far as I'm aware so I think
that he put that in there because like
oh my guy drinks blood these bats drink
blood it's all it goes together he can
turn into a bat because he could turn
into a fog and [__] too and I'm pretty
sure that that
I'm not really sure where that came from
you know what I mean but the bat thing I
don't as far as I'm a plague of rats too
yeah that's right as far as I'm aware
like they there was no thing where a
vampire could turn into a bat
the thing about like the old ancient
vampires or you know and even going up
into the Middle Ages and stuff like that
they didn't really have any like magical
powers necessarily I think maybe they
could kind of
teleport or something but they couldn't
they weren't like
um super super strong or they couldn't
like turn into mist or hypnotize people
or none of that kind of [__] that that's
pretty much all from the books and from
movies like I don't think any of that
was
part of like like I said I don't think
they had like any they were like
supernatural creatures I think but they
weren't really like
they didn't have all the powers that you
know get attributed to them nowadays
is what I'm saying
so um so yeah now the first time that
the word vampire
appeared in the English language like I
said there had been vampire adjacent
creatures prior to this but the First
Time The Vampire this word appeared in
the English language was in 1732.
and it was um kind of like some reports
about there were all these vampire
epidemics in Eastern Europe
um where
people were like I said becoming
convinced that these creatures were
getting up out of their graves and like
snacking on the townsfolk and so all of
these villagers were freaking out and
they were going in there and digging
people's bodies up and doing all this
[__] to like try and keep them from
coming out and like eating everybody you
know what I mean and usually
one big thing and this you know this is
another thing that uh
and this I think we talked about this
when we talked about the mercy Brown
vampire case too which was in um New
England
but this kind of [__] usually happens
when there's some kind of plague
or some kind of like epidemic in the
mercy Brown case it was tuberculosis I
think like in some other cases it was
all and it's usually in a place where
people don't
know what the disease is
and so all of these people like whole
families are dying and like nobody
really knows why so they're kind of just
looking for somebody to blame I guess
I guess and because there's these
stories about these revenants that go
around drinking blood and they're like
oh well that must obviously be the
problem so all we have to do is dig this
[__] up pin him to the ground
you know cut his head off or whatever
put a lemon in his mouth like they do in
some places I don't know what that's
gonna do but um you know and then Bob's
your uncle like everything will be
solved because it's like
Robert's your mother's brother as they
say they said another movie but yeah so
it's again people that don't know a lot
about disease
um looking for and understandably like
looking for a way to
fix it
because there's no way for them to fix
it they didn't have a cure or the black
death or tuberculosis or anything like
that back then I remember read when I
was a teenager that one of the earliest
benches or usages of the word vampire
was dubbed by a captain who was writing
a letter they had an old letter remember
some Merchant
the captain of certain Merchant rep
vessel was right to somebody else
say that there that it was getting drew
his blood was getting drunk and dry by a
bunch of lawyers he called them vampires
that's that was the
I remember that you couldn't find that
reference
now well I guess because he wasn't
talking about
actual vampires no it was he was calling
lawyers vampires right but that must
have been after the 1730s then I was
around that time because I remember the
1730s was the first at least in English
unless it was like in a different
language because like I said there had
been the first mention of the word
vampire
the oldest that we have I'm sure there
was using that word before that time
they're talking about some kind of
merchant some kind of merchant vessel
was used the word vampire they were
talking about lawyers yeah but like I
said that it by that time I imagine it
must have gone into like common usage
because the first English language use
of it is
I don't think it's spelled a v that was
probably the w
my power vampire like that well maybe
that wasn't English then because like I
said maybe because the first English
language was 1732 that they know and
that was referring to the actual in
German though Russia W was V so yeah
I know but I'm just saying that's
they're referring to like the actual
creature not just making a simile you
know what I'm saying yeah
but yeah so I've had like a lot of
people like particularly up until the
Middle Ages actually even after the
Middle Ages and into the modern day like
in some parts of the world
um people did really believe in this
[__]
so
you know so vociferously that you know
the minute something starts going wrong
in the village like people start dying
and nobody knows why they're gonna go
look for some [__] to dig up you
know what I mean they're gonna cut their
heads off and do all that other kind of
[__] put like garlic in there and it's
funny because people were wondering
about garlic too and I was just watching
this other documentary
and he was saying that he's like garlic
it's he's like it may seem kind of
random like that that would ward off
vampires and stuff but you have to think
that
um and most of y'all probably know this
but before they understood The Germ
theory of disease they thought that
diseases were caused by like miasma
spells smells like bad smells so they
figured that garlic because it smelled
so strongly could like drive out smells
that you didn't want and so because the
vampire was seen as akin to a plague in
a certain way
um or akin to a disease then ergo
the strong smell of the garlic would
keep it away so it's not as dumb as it
sounds or it's not as random as it
sounds like on its surface I guess when
you think about it that way because I do
kind of feel like they I mean the [__]
they were still thinking that bad smells
cause disease like up until
the late 1800s I want to say
before they figured that [__] out
weren't they well they figured a spell
had something in it
yeah because
which isn't a dumb thing to think
because it's like it does seem pervasive
and it does seem like it gets up here
right right so it is just kind of like
so it's like I said that's not a stupid
thing to think people today that don't
understand how [__]
shit's transmitted you know
it's a big difference like for instance
acquired immunity
it's where you're around a person that's
sick you get a few of the damn
bacteria in you or a couple of particles
that need to have the virus
it's a small amount of it and your body
fights It Off
it alerts how to fight it off
as you become immune to that disease
but it's a big difference between
getting a little bit of it and getting
bombarded by it
it gets sick
you know what I mean it's the same way a
vaccine works
if you could eject a small weekend a
battle that into a person and they can
learn an immunity
but the body can learn immunity through
exposure too but this that last time
this last pandemic went around people
got
so much this information and
disinformation
that
they weren't following science they were
following bucket
what do you call it [__] uh
[__] it was voodoo
you could get exposed to something and
and it's
you can look your body can learn to be
energy to it
to save as a vaccine
well if you're interested actually in
um the kind of
dawn of vaccines and how that all came
about there's a really good Monster uh
book and I think it's called the
speckled monster and it was about
how they found the cure for smallpox
yeah and it's a great book it's like a
really I mean it's one of those like
historical things that you wouldn't
think like you wouldn't think this big
because it's a big chunker of a book but
the story behind it is just so
compelling and like all of the people
behind it are so compelling
um and the fact that they believed that
it would work so much like this small
group of people that they were willing
to like give it to themselves and you
know they were their own guinea pigs and
they saved like you know millions of
lives because they actually found the
vaccine for small parts but um but yeah
it's a really good book I think it's
called the speckled monster I can't
remember who wrote it it came out like
years ago I read it probably like 10 or
15 years ago maybe
but yeah it's really really good
um so yeah
so uh so what are we saying okay so
because people back then didn't really
understand the germ theory of disease
um so when people died of tuberculosis
or something like that they're looking
for some [__] to blame they're
looking for a scapegoat right so they're
just like okay well we're gonna go stake
that person and then if they went and
dug up the person and the person looked
like they were kind of like
swollen
um and have blood on their face or they
looked fresher than they thought that
they should
um then obviously that was proof that
that person was a vampire like I said
this [__] with fangs and all that kind
of stuff that came around much much
later
um as far as I'm aware none of the
folkloric vampires had fangs that I
think that was like a like a fictional
invention that kind of came into the
lore and I think too that that was where
it kind of like cross-pollinated with
werewolves a little bit too because you
know those two monsters kind of like
cross-pollinated especially like
nowadays because there's so many like so
much overlap and they've done all the
you know all the fictional like
Crossovers and stuff but prior to that I
don't really think because like I said
I'm pretty sure like vampires couldn't
turn into wolves until Dracula came
along you know what I mean
um also
I see how okay so I always thought this
was funny so like I said even though
nowadays like vampire lore has it that
you have to be bit by a vampire or you
have to like exchange blood with a
Vampire to like turn into a vampire in
the original book Dracula
it seemed like
I thought it was like whoever he bit
would eventually what like when they
died they would turn into a vampire
which like I said
doesn't seem sustainable over the long
term because eventually like I think
somebody actually mathematically figured
this out but I can't remember how long
it would take not very long um spoiler
alert but eventually like everybody on
Earth would be vampires and there would
be nobody left to eat
so later on I think they did it where
you had to like exchange blood you know
what I mean because then that way you
know you could just kill them and [__]
like that the same thing would happen to
werewolves if every time a werewolf
attacked somebody
and just bit them and they didn't die
then they turned in a world pretty soon
everybody be werewolves you know what I
mean so it's that kind of [__] but
um one of my favorite things which this
seems like it would be really hard to
avoid but in some countries particularly
in some Slavic countries also in China I
believe
you can become a vampire
um like if after you were dead like an
animal jumped over you
I'm not really sure where that
came from or like why that would
specifically make you turn into a
vampire but that was one thing they
believed so it's like don't let the cat
jump over the dead body like you know
Grandma's dead body or anything like
that or she's gonna come back as a
Nosferatu
and all that other kind of [__] but uh
Chinese the Chinese vampires are
actually pretty interesting and there's
kind of like a whole I don't know if I'd
call it a sub-genre but there are like a
lot of
uh Chinese movies with the with the
Vampire
and the vampires are similar but they're
like they're slightly different I think
they're just kind of like a body they're
a Revenant but it's somebody like the
soul couldn't get out of the body or
something so he just like gets up and
keeps walking around and he drinks blood
and stuff but the vampire's there
they hop
and I've seen a couple of these movies
what are they called jiangxi I think is
what their Chinese vampires are called
and
it's kind of hilarious like I'm I'm
sorry I can't be intimidated by a
monster that just like comes hopping at
me like that like a bunny rabbit but I
guess that's scary and I don't know what
the origin of that is because I've seen
that in the movies I'm like what the
[__] and then like when I looked it up
later they're like oh yeah Chinese
hopping vampires that's what they do
they hop and I was just like why I don't
know why I'm sure it like makes sense to
them do you know why Chinese vampires
hop
because they can't walk
because they can't walk yeah it has to
be in a straight line too it doesn't
make any sense
because I was just talking about those
um it's called a jangshi right Jake Shi
I think yeah like the Chinese vampires
and they're just like boing boing boing
like coming after you guys it's bunch of
crazy rules yeah I don't I don't get it
either it has to do the crew wallet
chatted too the Great Wall there isn't
what wall there's many of it but the
Great Walls of China were to keep those
out too that Ghosts Out
keep it gotta keep out them hopping baby
couldn't any of them like hop high
enough to go over the wall I don't know
but the Chinese vampire little pogo
stick
I wonder if anybody made a comedy over
there about that that Chinese vampires
on pogo sticks that would be hilarious
please tell me if there's a movie like
that because I kind of want to see it
but yeah so um so yeah so I was saying
that in China and in some Slavic
countries you would also turn into a
vampire like if your dead body got
jumped over by like a cat or something
or a dog or any animal any animal that
jumped over your dead body would like
turn you into a vampire and like I said
um also if you had practice witchcraft
or did like some sinning or something
like that anybody was in danger you
didn't have to be bit by a vampire
that's the kind of [__] would just
happen
so we talked a little bit about this
before but there was also if you didn't
want your relatives coming back and
snacking on you then you could bury them
upside down like face down
um you could bury them
with um sickles like Farms Stripes sharp
farm implements sharp farm implements
that's what I was trying to say I'm not
drunk I swear not yet anyway
um
if you could do that like I said you
could throw out the the rice or the
knots or whatever so they would have to
like count it all and they would never
get up
that kind of [__]
um also some of the some people
would also like cut the um the tendons
like on their knees or their ankles so
they couldn't like walk around or they
would put like a bunch of [__] in their
mouth like rocks or bricks I think
actually like archaeologists
dug up I can't remember where it was but
they dug up this grave of this woman and
she had like a big ass
like brick like stuffed in her mouth and
they thought that it was maybe I mean
there was some other [__] in there too
but they think that that was maybe um
to keep her from coming back as a
vampire because they put like a bunch of
[__] in your mouth so you can't come and
like bite people you know what I mean
and that's another thing too is that I
think originally
when the vampires came back to
feed on you
they didn't necessarily I don't think
they were necessarily biting the necks I
think they like bit them like in the
chest like over their heart
so I think maybe the biting the neck
thing that might have also been a
fiction only
what happened in carmilla I haven't read
that in a long time I don't know my
sinuses are starting to loosen up now
that's good I'm good workers
just starting to be able to breathe
through my nose all these drugs I'm
taking trying to loosen all this stuff
and the booth the booze is probably
helping you this is let's just I was
gonna pretend that the Boost
to my bloodstream it is it's like an
antiseptic it's wipe it out all those
[__] yeah that's how I like to think
of it yeah it's good for you yeah I'm
gonna pretend probably not true but I
mean it's yeah it's good for him I kind
of feel like
um
but yeah so uh so in case like I said if
you there were a lot of other ways you
could identify oh my goodness that you
could identify I'll call attention to it
well it's kind of hard not to because
it's kind of like driving me out you
know
um
and I I remember hearing about this when
I was a kid because I had like all these
books about
vampires and witches and [__] like that
when I was little and I remember it was
maybe remember those books they used to
sell on TV that were what were they
called like The Unexplained or the
supernatural or something like that but
it was like a whole set of books it was
time Black Books yeah they were the time
life books yeah yeah magic yeah well
there was a couple different sets of it
like I had some of those and I had some
of the other ones too and they had like
all real nice illustrations in them and
[__] and the vampire one I'm pretty sure
had like a really nice painting of this
but there was a thing where if they
suspected that somebody was a vampire
they'd get a virgin boy had to be a
virgin so I guess it was like a little
kid yeah you would hope
um and would ride them around on a horse
which was also a virgin
the horse had to be a virgin too this is
Hardcore and so they would so they would
ride them around the cemetery and
whatever grave that the Horse stopped at
or wouldn't walk by or wouldn't walk
over or something like that they're like
oh that's where the vampire's grave is
you know what I mean
most of the time it was a black horse
but some countries had white
um also some if you had like a bunch of
holes like around your grave I guess
that was also uh kind of a thing but
yeah so so as I mentioned uh vampires
back then nothing like nowadays they all
looked kind of gross and I was kind of
thinking of looking like ticks you know
what I mean where they're all kind of
fat like fat with blood because they've
been feeding on everybody because that's
obviously what you would um you would
think also there were some in some
countries vampires could also do like
Poltergeist kind of [__] if you are says
Mysteries of the Unknown by timeline
that's what it was that's what it was
thank you thank you thank you yeah add a
bunch of those yeah but man myth and
Magic was another set another serious
set because I had some of those too and
some of them I checked out of the
libraries but because you could didn't
you you like ordered them
and um they would send you a new one
every month right yeah it was something
like that and I can never afford it but
I had a couple of that's before VHS you
had to get the [__] off books yeah I
still get [__] on books well people
bought encyclopedias back then yeah yeah
that's true
yeah that's what was the was the [__]
old Westwood
that yeah those were kind of cool too my
dad has
all of them they're leather bound oh
fancy good photographs of them
Ben said didn't Dracula establish the
thing about him creating Vampires by
sharing blood that's what I mean I'm
pretty sure that that was Dracula or
maybe like a little bit later because
prior to that you didn't have to have
been bitten by a vampire to turn into a
vampire or anything like that it was
just a curse yeah it was just kind of
like a curse or like it like I said it's
just some random [__] happened to you
like oh the dead bodies Grandma's dead
bodies laying on the floor and the cat
jumped over it oh [__] she's a vampire
you know what I mean like sometimes it
was just as easy as that because it was
all like very superstitious kind of
stuff so like I said I can kind of see
like when fiction writers got involved
in it they're like well obviously we
need to make this [__] a lot harder
otherwise everybody would be vampires
like I said I'm pretty sure somebody
mathematically figured out how long it
would take like if every time a vampire
bit somebody
that person turned into a vampire yeah
like how long it would take for the
whole world to be vampires and it's not
very long it was only like a few months
or something
and rice answered all that vampires
selected certain people to become
vampires yeah
they mostly killed people
which I kind of feel like would be the
same with
werewolves because like you know later
on and like I said I think this probably
came from the werewolf movies like The
Universal movies but um the whole thing
where if a werewolf bites you then you
become a werewolf too yeah but
um it's that's kind of the same thing
like everybody would be werewolves
unless but I feel like most of the time
would I wear open taxi we would just
tear your [__] face off youngsters
have not read and Rice's vampire
Chronicles go ahead and read them start
with Interview with the Vampire the very
first one they're great books
and uh you won't find any anything
modern like this you know it's very
detailed
had a very reasonable it makes a lot of
sense makes a lot of sense on the occult
level too it had rice to do what she was
talking about
well she did do a lot of research for
that and I actually like the the uh
Mayfair witches Saga too which is
actually pretty good I like the vampire
ones more vampires had their own culture
they selected certain people to become
vampires based about how good-looking
you were how much money you had
uh if you had a nice house or not
because they would like to steal that
you know they'd like to add you to their
Mafia
and uh
so there were there were certain people
that were like included in possible
vampire and excluded they also liked
people to be
they'd like to select people that had
Charisma but they liked ruthless Killers
to become a vampire
because they didn't want any
soft-hearted people be a vampires
because they wouldn't survive well
because yeah they'd be like Louie you
have to kill him he's one of the
characters in the book or you'd have to
eat rats right Louis was a soft heart of
vampire didn't like him he didn't like
the fact that he had to kill to survive
Jeff here said reminded me of the scene
with the horse at Mina's grave in
Dracula in 1979 yeah that's right they
did actually show that troop in the 1979
movie
Leslie said no one Dracula movie showed
Lucy killing the kids why
um I think the Francis the Francis Ford
Coppola one did actually suggest because
didn't Lucy come back to her when she
came back to her Crypt
she was holding like a bloody baby right
and she dropped it
didn't they have that in there keep it
with a hip if it yeah that's what I'm
saying she had yeah the infant was like
they challenged her and she dropped it
on the ground yeah tried to get back to
the casket
yeah that's right so the to the Francis
Ford Coppola one did show that yeah but
a lot of them don't and she looked hot
as [__] she was [__] pale and [__]
[Laughter]
I mean
drop that baby I think the baby was dead
too what
I thought it was crying because it
wasn't that a yeah because it was crying
when she came in the um I think it was
crap well yeah I kind of liked that
because that was one thing that always
like horrified me about the original
story like that I always thought that
was one of the scariest things was that
she was going around killing babies
essentially or like toddlers just like
snatching them well and Bryce called it
she said you know new vampires were weak
they had to go after weak weaker victims
and weaker prey
which makes total sense like they
haven't got all their [__] Powers
they start off weak and then over the
centuries they got stronger and stronger
and you could make a you could make a
vampire stronger week depending on if
you were a vampire that had decent
strength you could make another vampire
stronger weak depending on how much
blood you allowed him to drink from you
for her
they did have sex they were asexual but
they loved each other it was a weird
kind of like a
asexual they needed to have some kind of
a companionship towards each other they
would just get all [__] mad crushy on
each other or whatever you know oh yeah
and but but their idea of sex was
sharing blood
which is still like swapping bodily
fluids so it's kind of similar yeah they
were possessed by this dab
Poltergeist spirit
made of lust for blood
but it also gave him powers powers that
a poltergeist have and I've seen
Poltergeist you guys go back if you're
new to the show
yeah telekinesis
dreaming true knowing things
cryptic knowledge knowing things you
shouldn't be able to know uh weird stuff
like that
but a vampire could do that
reading that
they didn't get into that until I think
it was called Lasher
yeah that was the book I was thinking
yeah I started read about last year and
[__] and I was like man she did her
homework man yeah
but
I don't know if that's possible with
Poltergeist
I don't know if it's possible it would
have happened already you'd see vampires
and you don't see them unless they're
real sneaky yeah unless they're
listening to this show come get me
and we'll talk
you know where I live
we'll have a whole discussion about it
Mr 88 said everyone with children would
be vampires because toddlers bite ankles
but bite nonetheless
that's pretty funny toddler vampires
that's pretty entertaining Jeffy art
said a world of vampire sounds like the
plot of daybreakers with Ethan Hawke in
the movie The Blood is running out I've
been wanting to I think I saw it a long
time ago and I've actually been wanting
to re-watch that because I remember that
being really good and like really
underrated I mentioned this in the other
show
the vampires are not the main thing
though vampires are just popular in the
West
conceivably a vampire can only be
created by a stragoy which is there
which is like the the king of the Dead
they're
like a vampire but they could but their
whole thing is that's like the Romanian
version yeah
you're like a vampire
they look like a rat like bee
and they're kind of like the kegs of the
the undead of the Dead
their whole thing was familial familial
relationships they were all very family
oriented
uh they could have wives or husbands
depending on whatever sex they were
and uh they could cross breed with
living people
and corpses and the undead so these are
like the kegs of the undead
and if you look at the rules of the
struggoi it looks like a stragoi could
have sex
whether or not a dead person and that
that Undead person would give birth
to a living Undead which would never
kind of be like a vampire
the conceivably Dracula might have been
The Offspring
on other than that version of The
Offspring of a mortal woman and
Australia
that would make a vampire an event that
that vampire could reproduce by
spreading the vampirism
but there would be a subspecies that
would be the real species the real
species
yeah the real species would be a Starboy
which were better than a vampire they're
a lot stronger
uh not only because they could do all
this weird [__] with the dead of the
undead and to like have sex with a dead
body and it would give birth
to a half dead half-living creature or
like a like a zombie or a ghoul
they could they were also Sorcerers and
when you start bitching that kind of
[__] with magic
sorcery
oh man that's Unstoppable
because Dracula or the vampires they had
mental Powers evidently but it wasn't
sorcery
these guys had sorcery that's that's
like not giving Nazis magic you know
Magic Mountain no one wants to do that
that's going to be a bad time yeah now
the Nazis got magic
well like I was saying before I'm pretty
sure like vampires having hypnotism
powers or being like you know come to me
or whatever or like mind Powers I'm
pretty sure that was an a fairly recent
invention that might have come from
Dracula like a little bit before
um but I did mention earlier that in
some cultures vampires could do
Poltergeist [__] or Poltergeist [__]
would happen like when there was a
vampire around you but I don't know how
common that is Jesse I was talking about
half human vampires yeah
well if we talk about the half human
vampire you're also talking about blade
one of my favorite vampire [__]
series except blade three sucked but
[__] Jeffrey what's his name uh [__]
what's his name uh Wesley Snipes It's
nice Wes it's nice playing [__] blade
and he was The Offspring of a living
woman and a vampire he could walk around
during the day he had some vampire
abilities but he had a lot of a human
attributes too great great movies they
evidently tried to [__] reboot that
they're gonna [__] that up
blade was [__] from the 90s man and
it belonged to the night I mean it's
such a 90s 90s [__] movie one of my
favorite Vampire series even though it's
not like any of the other ones it's its
own thing it's action
very testosterone fueled
the only other series that's kind of
close to that is the one with the
vampires and the dab
werewolves what was the name of that one
that had the girl underworld underworld
I didn't like that I saw a couple of
them I liked it I need to go back and
revisit that
I just remember not really it I mean
action horror is not usually my thing
and I don't usually and I honestly I
don't even know if I would call
underworld a horror movie necessarily
it's just kind of more more like an
action movie that happens to have horror
type monsters in it you know what I mean
like it's not scary so I don't know so I
don't usually like that kind of I do
like blade and I like some other ones
that have that are more action oriented
and I just remember not really liking
underworld and I really did not like Van
Helsing at all that was a terrible
terrible movie I love Hugh Jackman but
nope wasn't having that but you know
what I mean I I don't know and I've said
I there's look there's a lot of vampire
movies that I really really like
vampires are not usually my to go to
Monster you know what I mean it's just
kind of like usually I'm just gonna like
as a vampire movie you know what I mean
but I don't know some of them are good I
really like I like the old school ones
like the universal ones I like the
hammer ones with Christopher Lee I like
all those
somebody mentioned Horror of Dracula
which also had Lucy bringing a kid into
the tomb and that's right I had
forgotten all about that one we just
reviewed that not too long ago the 1958
one
so yeah that did have Lucy brain she was
I don't think the kid was all bloody or
anything but she didn't have her like
bringing a kid so
so they did like um acknowledge that I I
can see why they don't because
they're cowards and they don't want but
it was in the book it was in the book I
mean you know what I mean but yeah
um I don't know I tend to like
I really liked
um the hunger
from 1983 which was based on a book by
Whitley strieber aka the guy that got
anal probed by aliens
um it's a good book though
um I liked that because it was
it had like a vampiric Romanticism to it
particularly the movie which was
directed by Tony Scott but it also had
like a modern scientific veneer on it I
really think this has opened up also I
could I could speak normally now yeah
man okay but I liked the Trope that in
case you haven't seen it in the Hunger
the main vampire in that is named Miriam
he's played by Catherine denove and she
is an ancient vampire like they even
show like some flashbacks she was like
in ancient Egypt or some [__] like that
so she's like thousands of years old
and she's evidently I think they imply
that she might be the only one
um but she keeps trying to make vampiric
companions because she's lonely
problem is that when she exchanges blood
with these humans like attempting to
make them a vampire like they'll live
for two or three centuries and then they
start aging very rapidly but they're
still functionally Immortal so they're
essentially their body is rotting while
they're still alive so that was like a
really horrifying concept and I really
like that concept and that hasn't really
been done much in movies you know what I
mean and I know it was from like I said
it was from a book
that was but I always really really
liked that concept and I kind of wish
some more well I guess
I guess you couldn't really do that
because it's so specific that everybody
would know where it came from you know
what I mean
Leslie Russell said Queen of the day I'm
copied the end of The Hunger 83 the
vampire's killing the queen yeah it did
kinda
and they were talking about Daughters of
Darkness that that was great yeah I
really like that one too that was kind
of like that's kind of a loose I mean
was Daughters of Darkness was the ones
like a loose adaptation of carmilla
there's been a lot of adaptations of
carmilla and I've I've never seen one
that was like super great I haven't read
Carmel in a long time
that's another thing I need to reread
you know what I mean uh Ben says was
dumpier invented for the blade comic
I don't know as a concept that word has
been around for centuries so I'm not
really sure because I haven't read the
blade comic so I don't know exactly what
the monster is in that lore but that
concept has been around for her people
forget about tight man that was those
that was a great those two movies were
great love to
really good vampire movie but like I
said that's action adventure yeah like I
said it's not I wouldn't even call it a
horror movie it's got Gore and [__] like
that but it's not like action adventure
vampire movie
if you haven't seen it go ahead and see
it Joseph mentions near dark which was
another great [__] that was a great
[__] vampire movie it's almost like a
vampire Western we reviewed that one not
too long ago yeah now that I'm thinking
about it
uh John Robertson did you ever figure
out where the native soil thing came
from or was that just from Dracula
pretty sure that was just from Dracula
and I'm not really sure
I mean that's the thing I kind of feel
like Bram Stoker
did so much
research when he was writing this book
he just like combed through
Legends and folklore and stuff like that
from all over Europe so he must have got
that from somewhere but I don't really
know where he got it from I mean it's
possible that he just completely made it
up
because you know to give Dracula a bit
of a weakness it's like oh he always has
to sleep in these boxes with his native
Earth in it like it gives him like a
vulnerability yeah so some kind of
restriction right because yeah because
otherwise he would be too powerful like
you wouldn't be able to defeat him you
have to give the villain like something
right so I look like a jack Ming the
merciless thank you for saying so man
because actually that was the idea
[Laughter]
my hair was starting to suck and I was
like man my hair kind of [__] sucks
I'm gonna shave this [__] off what's the
coolest looking ball dude that's out
there for me man [__] basketball side
out man [__] big merciles so I said
I'm gonna do like a big look yeah so
that was kind of the idea yeah
when you get jacked you look better with
your ball
if you're not jacked you don't look as
cool ball
I don't know what it is that's the rules
yes
or real skinny that works too yeah yeah
[__] um uh in that movie Max was not
jacked of course he was thin
yeah
[__] Mac side out was the [__] man I
love back yeah he's [__] great he's
one of those dudes that looked old even
when he was young
like I said he was in some ingmar
Bergman movies like back in the [__]
60s yeah and it was like he said he
didn't look it look like an old man but
he didn't look like a young man either
no it's because side I always had
[__] gravitas yeah he had a lot of
weight
yeah yeah
he was great in um what's that ingmar
Bergman movie hour of the wolf yeah I
love that movie if you're if you're real
into David Lynch and you haven't seen
hours of wolf the anger Birdman movie
please watch it because you'll see where
David or David Lynch got some of his
ideas from that movie is like creepy as
[__]
it's probably like I think it was like
the closest thing to like a horror movie
that Ingram Bergman ever did it's like
super creepy me and Jim were going to
make a [__] clitus and [__] um
General Kala outfits for [__] cosplay
yeah but uh now the way I look I
actually should do a jacked Ming yeah
yeah dude I wanted to do clitus if I
could do Ming and Jen could do [__]
General color yeah that would be cool
you just gotta make that [__]
headdress and that [__] collar that
she had that [__] was [__] stupendous
by hand you couldn't make that any other
way
they spent a lot of money on the on
those costumes
yeah they're cool yeah they'll show on
VHS you got to see that [__] in HD
flash coordinate HD looks [__]
fantastic
that's the way it looked at the theater
when I saw the kid I saw it I think
three times in a [__] row when it
came out I loved it I loved it just as
much as I liked Star Wars
there are certain elements I liked
better than Star Wars it had sex and
drugs in it
[__] power potions which are like
Viagra
for some chicks to bury you and [__]
that's a wild concept
Star Wars kind of played it safe but
the thing is that that's the way the
Flash Gordon Source material was though
if you watch the original Yeah we
actually we just watched one of the
original serials from the 30s yeah it's
on 2B they were wild man
yeah I mean they couldn't get away with
as much in the 30s as they can nowadays
but you could read between them but you
can still read between the lines you
know what they were talking about they
did get away with a lot of [__] yeah
like more than I would have expected you
know
um but yeah so fun facts like I
mentioned about the stakes before
um sometimes uh metal stakes and [__]
like that didn't work it had to be wood
and depending on where you lived it had
to be a particular kind of wood I think
the most common one was Aspen because
the legend was that that's what Jesus's
crossed that he was crucified on that
that's what wood that that was made out
of
so that was how that went but it's like
some other cultures used like Hawthorne
or some other like Woods like that but I
think Aspen was like the most common and
like I said it's weird because
I don't know if they'd say like oh metal
stakes doesn't work but a lot of them
since it had to be wood like it had
magical properties and um you know
obviously decapitation
also a pretty Fail-Safe method which
like I said will kill pretty much
anybody not just a vampire but my
favorite thing about the decapitation
thing is that some cultures
um like I think in Germany and like some
other places like some other Eastern
European regions
they not only cut the head off but they
would take the head and put it somewhere
else like they put it like between their
feet or like behind their butt or
something like that actually I think
like in I want to say it was like in
1990 like archaeologists like uncovered
this and I can't remember where it was
but they uncovered this grave that they
figured whoever had buried this person
or whoever had dug up and reburied this
person like thought this person was a
vampire because they had gone in there
and like rearranged their body you know
what I mean like they took the head and
like put it in the middle and then like
took their femur bones and like crossed
so it looked like a skull and crossbones
type of situation but they were thinking
that maybe because they found that's
kind of I don't know if I'd say it was
cool or not but I mean you know they've
been dead a long time but archaeologists
do find
more than occasionally grave sites where
they're pretty sure that the villagers
thought this person was a vampire
because they'll dig it up and there's
like [__] steaks all stuck through
there and heads cut off and stuff up up
their butt and [__] like that so it's
all that kind of stuff yeah John said
this that [__] Flash Gordon was more
irreverent yeah yeah definitely it would
definitely it was more
party drugs rock and roll [__] I
liked it but Star Wars I think evidently
was originally supposed to be like that
Star Wars originally supposed to have
like a disco soundtrack to it and
everything
I can't even imagine I mean I'm sure
somebody on YouTube has made a fan at it
like just to see what it would be like
yeah but
Mr 88 said but Star Wars had incest like
pre-taboo yeah yeah I mean kind of did
kind
but uh yeah because they [__]
retrofitted that [__] they're like oh
they're brother and sister no you have
to now everybody's gonna be weirded out
by all that flirtation that happens
Studios was the best [__] candidate
for uh flash Gord say with dude back in
the day they were real good with [__]
sci-fi but they were
good at making money at the box office
with their sci-fi that was the weird
thing about it I don't know why those
movies didn't really take off because
they're they're both Classics now
they couldn't follow up for some reason
in fact they should have made they
should have made uh sequels to Flash
Gordon it probably would have been
pretty good
but they were just like
Tila Renta Studios was always [__] up
they they [__] up a lot
um
like they should have made a a
John millius rated R follow-up to
[__] Conan they had a good property
right there they were gonna there's
gonna be two more Conan movies by him
but they didn't want to pay millius's
price
they said well we want to go
uh PG
of the second Conan and it just [__]
sucked that's never a good idea
they try to catch me if the first one
was R and that's not what delorenza
Studios was about anyway they were
supposed to be kind of like
the off brand you know and they were
supposed to be like the the the the
[__] uh uh the Indie [__] Studio
they should have [__] stuck to their
guns and did
Conan the Destroyer with [__] John
millius anyway because his Trilogy he
had this [__] [__] planned out it was
gonna be great
it's gonna end with King Conan
but they didn't do it it was going to be
like a a prehistoric answer to Star Wars
and he had it right milia snoot he was
doing even though it was wasn't quite
the same characters from the books you
know but it was still good enough it was
great for the screen
because he was teaching [__]
wagnerian
Nichi and lessons you know
it had a Mythos behind it already
Zach says fun fact delaurentis actually
produced a couple of Birdman's movies
for whatever reason that is very funny
and I actually didn't know that
he just had his little fingers in every
in all the pies didn't he yeah
um one thing yeah here's one thing that
I guess I never really made this
Association but you know in Hebrew
mythology Lilith yeah who that's also
vampire yeah I mean technically
um she's kind of like well she was
Adam's first wife yeah
um in in some of the stories although
where the character came from is much
older I believe it's from ancient uh
like Babylonian and originally I think
in the Babylonian stories and then I
think again later on she kind of became
a demon type
figure where she would go around like
drinking the blood of babies and [__]
like that yeah she was kind of like the
ancient Greek the the lamia and all that
kind of stuff these kind of correctly
she tried to
she tried to [__] Adam by trying to get
on top she tried to be [__] dominant
that was through the beginning of the
problems
you know what I mean like no we want
some woman that's going to keep her
mouth shut it'd be too much like a man
and go make me a sandwich [__]
she's just trying to be too much like a
band and [__] she got thrown out
yeah she she actually had a mind of her
own so like David
that's how that used to work back in the
old days but yes they turned they turned
her [__] ass into a demon
I can't blame her [__] man but yeah so
so there was a lot of that kind of [__]
going on
uh like I said even though I don't know
if technically you call it it's kind of
like a vampire because she goes around
like eating she's kind of a cannibal too
I guess because she eats people but she
also like drinks blood and [__] like
that
um but yeah
so uh something where there was
something else that I wanted to say
where was it it was like way down here
I was like I was kind of laughing too
because
there's kind of like a big
every now and then I'm really amused by
all of the theological discussions that
they used to have back in the Middle
Ages it just makes me it always like
amuses the [__] out of me
that grown ass men
were having these very very serious
theological debates over the nature of
demons and vampires and stuff like that
it's just I don't know and I know people
still do it nowadays and it's still
funny but it's like back then it's just
so funny because these are like the most
learned men in this in the society and
all this other kind of stuff and they're
actually like meeting in these rooms and
it's all very it's all very serious and
very glum and everything and they're
just talking about
just the most ridiculous
it was you know what I mean it would
just be like people talking about like
nowadays like [__] fictional like the
MCU or something like as though it was
real as though all these people were
real and all these people had magic
powers and [__] like that but talking
about it like super super seriously so
they're writing these [__]
you know treatises like the [__] Pope
wrote one and like mentioned vampires
and [__] like that I think they kind of
had a little bit and I think this
happened a little a little bit with
werewolves too is that
they almost kind of wanted to be like
they wanted them to like not exist
but then like if they did exist then
they had to be like demonic kind of
thing there so they were almost kind of
like it was almost kind of like a weird
like Catch-22 they had going on but it's
like that always like makes me laugh
that to think about all these very very
serious dudes like sooner I have these
very very serious theological
discussions about
vampires and like what they're gonna do
about it and it's just like I don't know
it's just very funny to me I know it's
like not funny because the implications
of particularly not so much with
vampires but I mean that [__] some
people over too but especially with like
Witchcraft and that [__] was not funny
because you know a lot of people got
horribly tortured and killed because
they actually believe in witches and
[__] but there was some crossover there
with werewolves as well because I don't
know if you guys know but you know
everybody knows about the witch trials
but they were werewolf trials too
because werewolves and witches were kind
of seen as related so some people were
hauled in on witchcraft charges and some
of the charges were being a werewolf or
changing into a wolf which was also
considered straight 88 points out this
is true that Star Wars exists because
George Lucas couldn't get the rights to
Flash Gordon
to Star Wars is a flashcard knockoff
actually
but a good knockoff became its own thing
yeah
but it's funny how DiLaurentis Studios
got the [__] rights to [__]
flashcard you know though and made a
movie that flopped
but I liked the movie I thought it was
great well and I think it's aged really
well like I think it's um I like it a
lot better now than I did
yeah the first time that I saw it like
it really kind of well I understand the
source material now a lot better now you
know
but I liked it when I saw it I was like
this is great
yeah I don't I don't even remember
definitely a trip I was like man this
would be great to see hi you know
we should do that one of these days yeah
get high as [__] and watch
that sounds like a party actually we
should probably do I'd be like a big
screen and [__] [__] with all the
[__] pretty
it would be like
so let's talk a little bit about before
I don't want to like go on all night
because and I still need to talk about
werewolves yeah but I do kind of want to
talk about some other a couple of other
vampiric creatures and I think a couple
of these we maybe talked about them like
on our because then we do like a kind of
weird Cryptids kind of show yeah and
they're because there are some
vampire like creatures from other
cultures
um that are pretty [__] crazy you
know what I mean and in particular I'm
thinking about the ones from
Malaysia
um and Indonesia and stuff and they make
like a ton of movies with these what's
up Oscar how you doing bro hey what's up
dog soldiers is the greatest werewolf
movie oh it's certainly up there there's
a lot of good werewolf movies I mean how
like one man what's [__] American
Werewolf in London yeah
and how yeah the howling one is good
yeah we just rewatched Ginger Snaps the
other day too I really like Ginger
Ginger Snap two is good
yeah we haven't watched the third one
yeah that's the pre that's it's kind of
like a prequel like it said a long time
ago but um
yeah but the ones I'm thinking of are
uh and I'm not really sure I'm
pronouncing this correctly but there's
one called Mana nanga
and that's the one they're usually women
so I think this is almost kind of like
an offshoot of like like I said like the
Lamy or the the Lilith kind of demon
where it's a woman
that can
pull off her entire torso like the whole
torso flies around like it sprouts bat
wings and [__] and it goes around and
these J they pretty much specifically
Target pregnant women
maybe not always but I kind of feel
that's like it's like Malaysia Indonesia
which is that yeah it's a similar kind
of thing where it's like where it's the
head but it's all it's also all the
organs like hanging down yeah and like
the head flies around and I saw a movie
and they had like a really long tongue
yeah and they go in there and like scoop
babies out their mom's voice
yeah from there's a lot of those yeah
and they're good because it's like a big
thing over there over there they take
that [__] seriously they're like that's
right the head did come off yeah they
actually stick to the lore and
everything it was good and they have
some like I said there's a slightly
different one where the whole torso
comes off and I think she has wings
right but it's a similar kind of thing
and I think she also goes after pregnant
women like I said they have super long
tongues too I'm pretty sure but yeah we
do I don't remember what the one was
that we saw but yeah it was it was good
they would stick to the Lord and do the
crazy [__] from the Lord
the head comes out yeah it was great
yeah Ben said Lilith was willful and
disobedient and she abandoned Adam I
think she was originally a Babylonian
goddess yeah it was just kind of like
everything else at that time
um a lot of the ancient beliefs that had
been around for thousands of years got
co-opted it was just kind of the same
way that when Christianity kind of took
over
um it kind of took all the old Pagan
religions and like made all that right
into demons it either Incorporated them
or made them into like bad guys kind of
like recessive right it's because
when you're writing Holy Scripture and
this is like a one of the rules of
writing Holy Scripture that they've been
following for thousands of years
the things that are accepted as common
belief in religions are have to be
addressed in the new religion
so you have to mention them and recast
them or reboot them as something else
that's why you have
Tiamat the space Dragon showing up or
the cosmic [__] chaos Dragon showing
up in the New Testament because people
believe that well those were around our
ancestors believed in them so those
things have existed you know but what
are they really like well it says right
here yeah that's all they're doing
it's just like comic book fans referring
to Old older comic books and older
superheroes that's all they're doing
yeah I mean pretty much yeah I mean it's
a good
um analogy like I know that people like
maybe get offended like if you say it's
like it's like comic books or like the
MCU or something like that but it's
exactly the same exactly it's just
storytelling right I mean that's how
humans write stories go back go reach
Joseph Campbell like uh God of a
thousand faces or the power of myth
those stories were real to those people
because there were real meaning behind
them cultural beatings behind them they
had to address them constantly over and
over again and they're handed down to
you
so anything from the Old Testament the
Septuagint Torah
or the New Testament they're talking
about other Babylonian and [__]
Mesopotamian and
Greco-Roman Gods constantly in there
they're just kind of rebooting them
slightly yeah but the people of those
days knew who exactly they were talking
about
they do well yeah like I said and I
think a lot of the sometimes confusion
or
um people reinterpreting things nowadays
is because you don't have the same
cultural context as the people back at
you know back then at the time had so
it's like we're looking at it through a
completely different cultural lens than
they would have been looking at it yeah
so I think that's where some of the
problem arises
but you know overall story is just to
teach lessons
what's a good way to put it
what is
um
Orthodoxy today was heresy when it came
out yeah you know what I mean so a lot a
lot of stuff is in there that you as a
Christian or a Muslim would think was
[__] heretical but no that was
Orthodoxy when that [__] came out
yeah it's Orthodoxy now
but they're talking about older gods
you know you have to talk about the
older Gods your ancestors believed in
them yeah so how do you explain them
that it's all included in there
Jason says Whitley Schreiber wrote the
wolfen that's right he did uh not sure
if this is considered a werewolf story
it's kind of tangentially the first kid
I haven't seen it forever I've been
wanting to re-watch that actually I read
the book as a teenager and I don't
remember much about it
but I remember seeing the movie on cable
many times back in the 80s we're like a
psychically linked wolf yeah yeah
something like that it's not exact it's
kind of more like a crime like a murder
mystery kind of more than like a horror
movie necessarily but I remember like
really liking it really stupid that's
crazy [__] right there I was
just talking about him earlier because
he also wrote the novel that the hunger
was based on like he's written some good
ass books but he's a little bit weird
he's a lunatic
how dare you yeah
Electrolux can
in case you're new here please watch
well I don't well I don't know if I want
to say this or not I'm not saying please
watch it but if it sounds funny to you
um you know his book communion where he
actually where Whitley strieber actually
really does seem to believe that he was
abducted by aliens
and was anal probed by a said aliens and
I think that's kind of where the whole
anal probe Trope came from probably from
that book because that book's been out a
long time
they made a movie of it with Christopher
Walken of all people what year did that
movie came we just reviewed it like a
few months ago oh this is 90s I think it
was I think it was 90s yeah early 90s I
had forgotten how [__] batshit that
movie is so quick
Christopher Walken was the perfect
person yeah I don't know what he's doing
in that movie
um
it's bizarre but the whole I mean the
whole you know the whole anal probe
scene is worth the price of admission
all by itself just his calm yet
indignant reaction just just thinking
about it makes me [__] crack up is
the Leisure Luxe Electrolux vacuum
cleaner hose comes out of the wall
how dare you
after they stuck a vacuum cleaner up his
butt yeah yeah I think I'd be a little
more mad than that I'm just saying but I
but I think the funniest part about that
was the fact that they just had it super
handy like it was just I like Flash
Gordon but it's no Star Wars exactly
it's no strong
Flash Gordon was Star Wars
when you're in full [__] hormonal rut
as a young boy and smoking weed that's
what's that that's that's what Flash
Gordon does you're under the effects of
[__] weed and [__] testosterone
yeah that's a deadly combination deadly
combination it says Aura I was dude I
was trying I was I was just I was
[__] floored by that this [__] was
sexual to me you know it was like
Manchester it's just a great movie they
had BDSM in it not the ball worms yeah
we're gonna use the ball worms on it
she's like oh I kind of like it lesbian
BDSM going on Clyde is [__] trying to
cut a deal with [__] emperor Ming for
a hit for the hand of his daughter you
have to get down torturing all that in
your barrier okay yeah yes my Lord
[__] [__] was creepy man [__] it was
a creepy flick I loved it
it was taboo that whole movie was
but that was the that was the idea
behind [__] Flash Gordon that was
that was the whole thing is that
flash was an American
all right he was pure of heart he was a
good person so was Dale and [__]
the doctor what was his name doctor
[__] whatever his name was the guy
who made the rocket I know I can't Dr
rocket the Migos or the the Mingos or
the [__] mongos whatever you call
them
were basically Europeans they were
[__] corrupt and [__] they were
they were sexually open people you know
they they weren't that cool we can't
have that can't have that and they were
also fighting to killing each other you
have to be all up they were a bunch of
they were a bunch of dictators they were
a bunch of dictators and [__]
and uh so that that was the meaning of
[__]
oh that was the meaning of Flash Gordon
it was very American perspective
commentary on the outside world
and then the good American
flashcard gets them to all agree and
make peace with each other
that's just looking pie the sky American
mentality we're gonna fix the world
that's what they're saying good luck
with that
um but yeah good luck that's what I just
said yeah Ben says the uh what what did
I just say was called The Pentagon or
whatever uh was one of my nominations
for the nastiest Undead in d d in a live
stream a while ago I mean that honestly
that monster
is probably one of my favorite
World monsters because it's just so what
a [__] up idea
I mean how would you even come up with
that who came up with that like I know
somebody had to come up with it at some
point like I know that it was probably I
don't know but I'm just fascinated by
where myths come from and I know it's
not usually one person coming up with
the [__] but it's just kind of like a
conglomeration of
a bunch of different stuff that's going
on but it's like what a weird what
situation
would have
cut would have brought that about like
we have a demon vampire creature whose
head comes off oh with all the stuff
attached and floats around with all of
her little guts just hanging and she
goes around this big long tongue and
like sucks babies out of wombs
who would come up with that I mean they
came over I mean that's pretty Kick-Ass
that's pretty creative so it's just kind
of that's a lot more creative than like
[__] we came up with like the first time
I saw that like the first time I saw
that in a movie and I was like what the
[__] is happening right now oh my God
it's like that's the craziest [__]
thing I've ever seen and then I was just
kind of like what would have made them
think of that because the thing about it
is that if you think about the myths
behind you know vampires or werewolves
or zombies or whatever
or witches it's like you can see how
they got from point A to point B like
you can be like okay like you know the
vampire Legend it's like well obviously
people didn't understand bodily
decompass decomposition people that
understand the germ theory of disease
and they'd understand how tuberculosis
spread or the plague spread or anything
like that and you know so that kind of
like informed
all of these stories and you can totally
see if you put yourself in that mindset
you can totally see where that comes
from the thing about somebody's head
popping off and floating around with all
of their guts their organs like hanging
down from the neck it's like how
how like how would you even think of
that I don't even know like how you
would think of that so like I said
that's surely one of the most creative
vampire monsters that's for sure
um so yeah there are still
people that apparently still believe in
Vampires nowadays and I'm not just
talking about Goths that think they're
visaga or whatever
um
there are like some places like even in
like Romania and stuff like that where
people still think hey the relatives
still you know like in kind of back
Waters showed up yeah I see that I see
that
um but yeah so so the [__] is still
happening also Wikipedia categorizes the
chupacabra as a sort of vampire like
creature which I guess it is that's
marginal because it's person
I mean you know a vampire vampire is
generally like a person or was a person
it's like a Revenant it's like an undead
person
I kind of feel like if you're getting
into animals
then you're getting into Cryptid
territory and then you're expanding the
definition of vampire to us to a point
where it's meaningless you know what I
mean
I mean yeah the chupacabra in some
Legends
does suck blood I mean isn't that what
the name means goat sucker yeah so you
know what I mean but I don't know if I
would necessarily call that it's
vampiric sure but I don't know if I
would
necessarily like call that a vampire you
know I don't really know
but yeah let me see if there's anything
else that I did not cover oh I did want
to cover this because
I remember reading this this being a big
Theory and I think this came out like in
the mid 80s
we're like this dude who is a biochemist
his name was David dolphin of all things
and dolphin just like the animal
he came up with the idea and I think it
proliferated for quite a while because I
remember hearing a lot about this that
it could be that because there was like
a big rash I feel like in the 80s for
trying to come up with
real things that might be behind certain
myths and legends
so he proposed that maybe the some of
the vampire myths came from people that
had
um porphyria
yeah I heard it
um but here's the thing like because
he's like yeah people with that they
have like light sensitivity and they get
like you know lesions on their skin and
like they
um their gums and their nails like
recede so it looks like red or they look
like they have fangs or something like
that and they try to like stand at the
sun because they're really sensitive to
the sign of bloody block
so it kind of sounded reasonable on its
face and I remember hearing that and
being like oh yeah that sounds
reasonable and I think it was even in
some of my books it might have been they
might have talked about it on like some
documentaries and [__] like that
but then and I can't believe I didn't
really think of this but they're like
here's the problem though the vampire
myth arose you know thousands of years
ago and originally what we would
consider as vampires were more like
ghouls they didn't look like what the
fictional vampires look like nowadays
like super pale staying out of the sun
all that kind of [__] had not existed
the Lord didn't exist yet like when
vampires were in bed so he was like
trying to explain like the fictional
vampire rather than the folkloric
vampire is what they were saying the
thing is those people that were sick
that had things like profyria didn't
survive in the back in the old days
there's a cure for it now to die yeah so
I don't I don't think that there would
have been any Legends built around them
they'd have been very rare the people
didn't really keep records as well as
they do today
you'd have seen a person who had a weird
illness in a small area
localized area a little town didn't live
for a little while then died and been
forgotten
it wouldn't cause a lore
yeah and like I said all of the vampire
lore had been established
you know prior to an original vampires
didn't look like the later right the the
way we think of vampires nowadays the
way we thought of vampires in the 80s
when he came up with that theory was
informed by pop culture it was informed
by novels and stuff like that that
wasn't what the folkloric vampire was
like that's not what they were talking
about that's not what they were talking
about they were talking about basically
a ghoul that came out of the ground like
I said right and I kind of think that
that probably came from people not
understanding body decomposition and
also how diseases spread right like
various diseases people were done out of
other [__] diseases they had they
couldn't see it so it must have been
some spiritual they dig up a person that
they suspected was doing it and they say
hey that motherfucker's not totally
rotten
but they didn't know that a body could
be preserved underneath the ground quite
for quite a while
if the temperatures are right yeah I
mean it happens yeah
I mean under certain
circumstances they've dug out bodies
that were like you know hundreds
thousands of years old that still I mean
they didn't look like they were still
alive but they still look pretty good
still had skin and hair and [__] like
that just depends
where you're at depends on the climate
yeah generally
but um if you ever read it if you ever
read a book about
um those body Farms
where they do outside where they do all
the research well they don't just leave
them outside they put them in all
different kind of they submerged some in
the water they put some in dry
conditions some wet conditions they just
wanna yeah they're just seeing like how
because you know for um it's gross but
you can try you can yeah for a crime
forensics you can I've read like a
couple books about it and it's actually
it's disgusting but it's like actually
pretty fascinating like that they and a
lot of people donate their bodies to
that because it helps forensic science
you know
there's photographs of a guy who died at
Sea in his old boat and the boat was
adrift for years like five or six years
they found that boat he was there dead
at the dab dinner table
put the little table inside the [__]
inside the living quarters of the ship
and he looked pretty
intact
he was green I think but
he looked there wasn't anything to eat
him he was at Sea yeah he'd have maggots
I guess
I mean if you are far enough out to see
I guess flies couldn't get there yeah he
dried out so it became kind of like a
green mummy so he's like jerky yeah
human jerky yeah both [__] that's
creepy [__] that boat was out there for
years by itself see that kind of stuff
is like that's creepy yeah I don't know
why it's creepy it just is yeah it was a
ghost ship yeah because all you could
think of is just that dude that dead
body just floating around out there yeah
all that time it looks Sinister but it
was he died of a heart attack yeah well
I see that's what I mean like if you
think about it it's not scary but but
it's still I think most people would
still think that was creepy yeah it'd be
very creepy if you found it but he was
just that he was just out fishing in his
fishing boat and [__] happened he died
of a heart attack yeah yeah
um let's see what uh oh they're talking
about cocaine bear
Ben said great film when is the review
coming out we still need to see cocaine
bear you haven't seen it yeah yeah we
haven't seen it yet I do want to see it
Joseph said David Drake wrote a story
called The Red leer about a rare
dinosaur
well I guess the velocipaster was kind
of like a where dinosaur was philosopher
is fun one of the best movies ever made
that's
cinematic gold it sounds crazy it really
is but you see it you'll understand but
technically isn't he I gotta have that
[__] on Blu-ray isn't he a weird
dinosaur
okay he turns into a dinosaur yeah yeah
he's lucky yeah so I guess technically
he's wearing that I'm sorry
yeah that works
um but yeah tinkle wrote that [__]
did I tell you guys that I was I I don't
remember if I told you I know I told him
I was at the bookstore the other day and
I saw a novel by Chuck tingle
like an actual
dead trees paper novel like it was
hardback I can't read what it's called
now
Camp something it looked like a slasher
and I was like now I kind of feel like I
want to buy that
just because pretty sure it's the same
Chuck tingle
well it didn't look it wasn't erotica
and it wasn't it didn't have any
dinosaurs or gay airport yeah the author
the author picture was it him and a ghee
oh I didn't see it
now so if we go to the bookstore this
weekend I'll look all right I just
thought like I happen to be looking for
something else and I was like what the
[__] I thought he just wrote ebooks that
were like you know I don't think it's
the same guy it's got to be who else has
that name come on
you could probably I don't know
all right so
um yeah so uh so the poor furyth uh
porphyria thing that was um kind of
debunked a little bit some people have
also tried to maybe associate rabies
like maybe people that had rabies uh
that maybe that was something that was
that kind of maybe informed the legend a
little bit which I guess sounds a little
bit more plausible
but you know what I mean I I kind of
feel like it's probably a lot simpler
than that I don't think the medieval
people were that observant they just
made up stories although I mean what
else was there for them to do really
they just made up stories that's true I
mean it could be
here's here's another fun fact that I
learned I think I I feel like I kind of
knew this fact before and then forgot it
but then I relearned it again
is that you know how you know Dracula
has the cape and everything nowadays the
cape only came about because when they
were doing a Stage production of Dracula
they thought it would be easier to make
the character like a like disappear if
he had like a big ass cape on so that's
why they put a big escape on him and
that was due to belugosi time stage play
yeah we're like yeah because the the
1931 movie was not it was based on the
novel ish but it was actually based on
the stage play that was based on that I
understand it the whole idea of a
gentleman
aristocratic vampire that you're seeing
was a bellagosi thing now that came from
I told you that came from the vampire by
John polidori yeah but what he was doing
[__] Dracula he was dressed in that
cave yeah that [__]
basically they have tuxedo style uniform
it's Bella Lugosi that came up with that
they asked me he made that whole costume
well he was he was reprising his stage
role yeah hold the stage yeah yeah but
I'm not sure if he was the first actor
to play Dracula though
yeah like on stage I mean right that's
not what I'm saying right I'm saying
that with your thinking of Dracula
you're actually thinking of belugosi's
stage Act
which is crazy because I mean that movie
came out you know almost 100 years ago
now which is [__] insane to think
about because we just watched the [__]
the other day and people still watch it
but it's just kind of like every
if you tell somebody to do like a
stereotypical vampire they're doing
Bella Lagos
yeah which is
I think he would if if he was still
alive now if he could somehow bring him
back from the dead like a vampire and
you could like and you could show him
that I think he'd think that was pretty
cool yeah maybe although I think
Bram stroker stoker fan stroker that's
what I said stoker I'm gonna say
whatever
that like stroke okay look that dude
that wrote the [__] book
he's really talking about Max Shrek
though I think
see I kind of feel like I'm talking
about dibella goes he's talking about
yeah I mean in the book yeah he looks
kind of he looks like an old man like a
rat like old man yeah so he's not
talking about Bella ghost he's talking
about Mac Shrek now he does get younger
like he looks younger when they see him
later like after he starts snacking on
everybody in England yeah like as he's
getting kind of his power back because I
think the implication in the book was
that that was why he was looking like a
wizard old man was because he was
running out of people to snack on like
where he lived and that's why he needed
to go to London because that's where all
the yeah because that's where he was
draining them all dry around there so
he's like why I need to go somewhere
there's like a high population density
so there's more people for me to like
snack on so that's why he went but it's
like over the course so they did kind of
get that right in the Francis Ford
Coppola one where he looked kind of like
like an old man at the beginning but
then like he got younger like as he went
you know what I mean he did mention that
in the book that like when they see him
in England he looks younger like you can
still tell it's the same dude but he
looks younger but yeah when Jonathan
Harker first gets to the castle he looks
like a yucky
like a not quite as bad as Nosferatu
like he didn't look like a monster
monster but he looked like kind of a
yucky old man
like you know
so so that's yeah so the whole Bell of
the ghosty thing where he's all like
kind of young and Suave and everything
that's that's a fiction only that's
that's from the movies that's not from
the book
I still think the max Shrek images
closer to what they're talking about
because
it is closer with Stoker's talking about
it's a [__] strong boy
he's rebooting the stragoy which is the
struggle he looked like a [__] rat it
looked like [__] Mac Shrek back
Shrek's Nosferatu character I think
that's probably what they're talking
about but it doesn't matter we just
watch fictional we just watched the
original Nosferatu again the other day
and it's like and because we'd just
watched shadow of the vampire again not
too long ago and I was like I kind of
want to watch the original Nosferatu
again because I haven't seen in a long
time and Max Shrek still looks creepy as
[__] in that [__] movie Steve the
Stephen King's television version of
[__] sounds like
Mr Barlow is probably what
Brad Stoker's talking about
I really like Barlow's what he's talking
about I really like Kurt Barlow yeah
like he looks really cool yeah that's
Reggie and Alder by the way playing him
yeah he was in an episode of Thriller
that I just watched the other day
and I was like and I was like hey it's
Mr Marlow in a completely different yeah
you know he was playing a human
obviously I got it I got that [__] on
Blu-ray too
Salem's Lot it's like it's a good it's a
good program that's a really good
adaptation yeah that's a really good
adaptation it's made for TV
but uh but like I said it's Toby Hooper
he made [__] Texas Chainsaw Massacre
and life force yeah it's real good and
the fun house you know he knows what
he's doing and also maybe Poltergeist
although there's like argument over
whether Steven Spielberg directed that
or typical Cooper did so you know what I
mean
so there's that whole argument
but yeah
I don't think I mentioned Varney the
vampire but that was another kind of
early that was a Penny Dreadful uh that
was another thing that kind of informed
I don't think it was quite as
influential like I said the vampire by
John polidori which was based on Lord
Byron because polidori was Byron's
physician
um was kind of the first to introduce
a lot of the tropes that we would
recognize in the sense of Dracula as an
aristocratic character instead of like a
ghoul type monster so there was that
then like I said there was Sheridan
lefanu who wrote carmilla that came out
in 1872 like way before Dracula and that
introduced kind of like the lesbian
vampire angle
um also very good and then Dracula came
out in 1897 which kind of like cemented
all of the stuff that we know about
vampires nowadies which like I said most
of which comes from
the books and the movies it doesn't
necessarily come from from folklore
other than a few things like steaks and
garlic and
you know maybe mirrors in some cultures
but
um you know in crosses and stuff but
it's most of the stuff like about
vampires having to be invited in or like
them turning into bats or the fangs or
things like that them being gaunt and
pale and not being able to go out in the
sunlight and stuff like that that was
all like later that all came from the
books and the movies
so yeah all right so let's start talking
about werewolves where it gets too late
because like I said I gotta get up very
early in the morning so I don't want to
go on all night but this is a fun topic
you know what I mean I don't quite as
much on werewolves because there's like
I said there's a lot of vampire werewolf
crossover
and I think kind of the same thing
happened
with werewolves has happened with
vampires in the sense that a lot of the
[__] that we know about werewolves like
if you ask anybody about werewolves
nowadays everybody say oh you know
Silver Bullet and it kind of looks like
a dude and a wolf like hybrid and stuff
like that most of that was from the [__]
about the full moon and all that
almost all of that was from the movies
and uh in a sense I think a lot of that
came from the Wolfman the 1941 movie
with um with uh launching launch any was
in there right yeah
so um so yeah that's uh all that stuff
kind of uh came from that and just like
the vampire Legend
in the Original Stories you didn't have
to
get bitten by a werewolf or attacked by
a werewolf to become a werewolf
um it was usually a similar kind of
thing to like a vampire where
um it's actually in the earliest stories
becoming a werewolf was like a
punishment usually from one of the Gods
like you did something to piss off one
of the Gods and they turned you into a
werewolf like as punishment
um so so there was that so I kind of
feel like the whole thing about oh just
turn it into it like every full moon or
something like that that's a pretty
modern uh concept because a lot of the
old stories were uh not like that
but
but back to ancient times and I feel
like
the werewolf Legends
is not as
I don't understand I don't think the
vampire Legend is all that weird but the
werewolf legend is considerably less
weird because you can see a through line
as to why humans would have come up with
that and why cultures all over the world
have stories about
people turning into predatory animals
and it's usually whatever animals are
predatory in their particular
area you know that they're from so it's
just kind of like you know in South
America or Central America or whatever
it's like they have weird Jaguars and
it's like in you know Africa or whatever
they would have like where lions or wear
crocodiles or whatever and then like in
India they would have like where tigers
I mean so it was whatever kind of the
apex predator
in your
area was they had stories about people
that could turn into those yeah the
Islanders like Hawaiians
Polynesians they had stories about
[__]
sharks
sharks and I think the head kind of
things are kind of like rare sharks
wouldn't that be cool being a whale
shark
I don't remember how the exact story
exactly went but
I had heard about that yeah that's a
that's kind of a Polynesian yeah
so here's here's the thing would you
rather be like given the choice would
you rather be a vampire or a werewolf
I'd rather be a vampire
you think probably
I probably would too because I like the
immortality thing yeah even though like
I said I'm pretty sure immortality was a
later construct as well I don't I don't
think that the original ghouls or
anything like that were I don't think
it's mentioned if werewolves are were
Immortal no I don't yeah I don't think
they are I think they're just regular
but well the thing about it is that
being a vampire would be super cool but
like in some ways it would be a super
pain in the ass too so in that way like
a werewolf being a werewolf would
probably be like a lot at least in the
modern concept of it would probably be a
lot less of a pain in the ass because
it's just kind of like oh it's the full
moon I'm gonna turn into a wolf for a
couple of days or whatever and run
around and like kill deer or whatever
but then you could be like a normal
person the rest of the time wolf would
be about live fast Die Young I think and
[__] vampire would be like more about
[__] slow down and try to live for as
long as you can so it's like a Sprint
versus a marathon I guess it would like
depend on the kind of person you were I
kind of like because I was saying this
while you're gone it's like even though
I feel like people have tried harder to
explain the origins of the vampire
because it doesn't seem quite as
um obvious
I don't feel like you need to go too far
to explain the origin of werewolves
or where whatever Predator is in the
area because every culture
has these kind of I mean you know we are
animals you know we evolve from animals
um we compete with animals for food not
so much nowadays but you know back in
the day we did so we're going and we're
part of the natural world so there's
going to be stories about
you becoming the apex predator that
you're and particularly in cultures
where you are competing with Wolves for
the same food source essentially
which a lot of times they were
um you're gonna
identify with that Predator because you
are also a predator so you're gonna be
like oh well this Predator he maybe is
better at it than me so I'm going to you
know kill the wolf and wear his skin and
that'll give me his Essence so it's like
to me that seems not as weird you know
what I mean because we're just animals
and werewolf the werewolf stories are
about bestialism yeah basically it is
not carnal lust and there's a reason why
throughout history most of the
werewolves that you hear about most of
the legends about werewolves are almost
always men yeah there have been some
female werewolves but not that many I
mean recently there have been two like
in movies and stuff like ginger snaps
and stuff but because I like that they
they kind of tied the whole werewolf
thing in with um with menstruation
because you know the cycles of the Moon
and all that kind of stuff which I
thought was a good idea but prior to
that I feel like it's almost kind of
like it's almost kind of like a Jekyll
and Hyde thing where it's like because
you have all of these Primal
urges and you have and people have these
fantasies about just like letting them
out and just being an animal and not
worrying about so like I said that's not
weird Well story is just is a man as
Beast story yeah man embracing his
beastial nature yeah that's exactly what
that is so like I said I feel like it
needs less explanation you're right yeah
because it's something that a lot of
people and honestly if you I don't know
about now but I know that one of the top
categories of erotica at least a written
erotica is
werewolf type stories or beast on you
know like Beauty and the Beast type
stories
you know what I mean
um a lot of people really like those
like it's a huge huge sub genre it's a
huge huge sub-genre people with a guy
who's he's hot as a [__] he's
[__] uh
he's handsome but he's powerful but he's
[__] beastial all right now you have
to have sex with him that's what they're
talking about oh no oh no he's the first
he's not quite human
he can beat up any other man he's
dominant as [__] it's all yeah I want to
surrender to it it's always kind of like
the ultimate yeah bad boy yeah ultimate
bad boy type story it's like he's an
actual he's an actual animal but he can
also like I'll talk to you well there's
different versions like I said it's
these you know because these are this is
mythology it's like kind of hard to pin
down because some versions
um you know particularly like the really
old like the ancient versions of the
stories like you just turn into a wolf
and you're just essentially a wolf like
you don't retain any of your human
characteristics where I kind of feel
like in more modern iterations of it
um it's more of a man wolf hybrid which
is kind of more a new thing yeah yeah
and he does seem to retain some of his
human faculties whereas back in the day
I think it was just he turned into a
wolf and you just turned into a beast
and you didn't know what you were doing
there's a lot of CGI porn of this
[__] hot women with these [__]
werewolves like something out of dab
out of the highway
you know he's got a human shape
but he looks like a wolf it's just
bawling he sent me this thing on
Facebook the other day
it was like it was um
like uh animated yeah like CGI
and it was just it was funny because
almost like a like a repeating GIF but
it was just kind of like a like a
werewolf like [__] a human let's like
don't put it on the screen I don't think
it'd get tagged
she's not [__]
it'll get tagged uh you think so yeah
it'll get attacked let's see if I have
it Ben says lycanthropy jumps between
humans and local fauna yeah
and that's the thing I kind of feel like
like I said I just I feel like there's
not as much to explain here but so
it's just kind of yeah
and we just got demons yeah yeah well
you don't think so you think we did yeah
it's that good almost all of our [__]
gets demonetized you know that right
it's that good at recognizing it yeah
I mean I like pretty much
75 of our stuff gets demonetized because
of like [__] you say and [__] you show
on there [__] I say this [__] yeah
you said something oh I I think that
they what did I say that it gets well
like you know because when we start
talking about like porn and all that
artists and stuff yeah so you know what
I mean so we usually get to monetize
[__] up then but I'm just gotta we gotta
be on We I'm telling you we ought to
take the show to rumble because they
won't they won't censor it I need more
ice yeah here if you take the show to
Rubble
we'd be able to [__] have a clean
show all through it they don't care
Jen says werewolf for me
I kind of yeah that's the thing I think
I'd probably rather be a vampire because
I want to live forever and that would be
really cool but um but werewolf like I
said seems like it would be cooler
because it would be like a lot less
fuss you know what I mean like you could
live as a regular person but then like
every now and then you'd be like oops
gotta go do my werewolf [__] you know
what I mean
but I don't know like I said there's no
there's no hard and fast rule over like
nowadays everybody knows oh vampires are
Immortal although like I said that's a
modern Construction
but werewolves I kind of feel like it's
all over the place like someone might
think they're just like regular people
that can turn into wolves and I don't
know if they necessarily live forever or
not I'm sure in some mythologies they do
but that's the thing you can do kind of
anything with it nowadays
so
um
so as I mentioned before we were talking
about the first references to werewolves
there is actually a reference to a
werewolf
in the Epic of Gilgamesh
um in the sense that and this is going
back to what I said before where
wolves usually the story of a werewolf
like from ancient times it was almost
always
um becoming a werewolf was almost always
a punishment from a god like you did
something to piss a god off and they
turned you into a wolf
you know what I mean it wasn't a good
thing so in the Epic of Gilgamesh
um Gilgamesh uh he actually like Ishtar
who's a goddess she like comes on to him
and he's like uh nah and so basically
so that happens
um and he doesn't want to [__] her
because she was an [__] to another
boyfriend that she had who was a
Shepherd like he turned like she turned
him into a wolf right
and then made him eat all his own sheep
which is kind of a dick move
so so there's that so like I said it was
kind of like a punishment but it was
mentioned in the Epic of Gilgamesh which
is what how many [__] years old 3000
years old something like that but it's
like it's the oldest written yeah story
older than bible stuff way older yeah so
yeah but there there is a mention of
somebody getting like a man getting
turned into a wolf in that which like I
said you would consider a werewolf now
there's also a mention in uh the the
Metamorphoses by avid
and this is PR this is probably one of
the most famous like ancient werewolf
stories so there's this traveler he goes
to uh King lycayon
um of Acadia or Arcadia I've seen it
both ways
now
um Lycan suspects that this visitor is a
god
um I've seen versions where it's Zeus or
Jupiter which is kind of the same thing
as I'm gonna do a trick on this God for
whatever reason I'm gonna serve him
human meat and see if he realizes that
it's human meat in some versions of the
story he just like plucked some random
[__] and Cooks them and in other
versions of the story he actually Cooks
his own son which seems a little far to
go to
pull a prank on
Zeus but okay
so he does that and Zeus Jupiter whoever
the God is like obviously is a God so
knows immediately that this is human
meat and this is a pretty [__] up
thing to be doing uh dude
so he turns like hand into a wolf so
again punishment by a God that was kind
of like the earliest all the earliest
references to werewolves were always
punishment by a god there was no
uh there was there was no thing about
like
being
um bitten by a werewolf and then turning
into a werewolf like later on
now interestingly so his so King like
hand that's where the word lycanthropy
came from obviously
um now originally the word lycanthropy
referred not necessarily to a person
that could turn into a wolf but it
referred to what nowadays we would call
a mental illness about somebody who
thought they could turn into a wolf but
it was like a delusion you know what I
mean because there is that is a thing
um still nowadays and they still call it
that too as far as I know I don't know
if they have like a more modern name for
it but they do still call it that
where you don't actually turn into a
wolf obviously but you
you think that you do it's it's a
delusion that you turn into a wolf and
like start acting all wolf and [__] like
that so that's still what they call it
so those were actually like the first
uses of that word actually referred to
somebody with a delusion it didn't refer
to somebody that actually like turned
into a wolf
so uh so yeah so let me see where I was
with the notes
I lost my place
but yeah so excuse me so as I mentioned
before
all cultures have stories of you know
like I said wherever you live whatever
the apex predator is whatever the main
Predator was that was competing with
humans for the same food source is
usually the source of
whatever the werewolf or were leopard or
wear tiger or whatever the legend is
um obviously also Native American
circles you had the skinwalker which is
kind of a similar sort of thing they
have they had their own kind of stories
about that which is kind of similar
people that could
um that could change into various
animals
so
this so like I said I kind of feel like
the whole
the whole modern conception of a
werewolf being a wolf man hybrid and
that's actually kind of what the word
werewolf means it just means man wolf
but pretty much unless I'm mistaken all
of the earlier stories about werewolves
we're all about a person being turned
into an actual wolf now whether they
still had some semblance of human
consciousness that kind of varied
but in all of the old stories that I'm
aware of
um the human just turned into a wolf
they didn't it wasn't like a combo of of
a human and a wolf you know what
so uh so as I mentioned
um I kind of feel like
because it was
considered punishment at the beginning
and then later on it was kind of
crossbred with witchcraft
uh you know people that practice
witchcraft during their life or did
various things like that like sometimes
they would become werewolves as well
um so or if you were just like a shitty
person also I kind of feel like there
was a conception
that and this happened in a few cases uh
there was a guy in I think it was in
Germany
whose name was Peter's stub or stube or
stump
um who was essentially well allegedly I
don't really know because
it was back in the old days when they
would torture you
and they would you know and if you
torture somebody they'll say all kind of
crazy [__] so yeah he's like oh my God I
totally turned into a wolf and like ate
my family and all this other kind of
[__]
so um so I don't know if you really did
the stuff or not
but um
so it could be too that people who were
particularly egregious
serial killers
back in the old days like back in the
medieval like ancient to Medieval Times
people didn't have a concept of a serial
killer I guess
so they thought to themselves well
anybody that's doing anything that
[__] up
can't be an entire person so there must
be something wrong with them there must
be some kind of like animalistic
something or other so I do kind of feel
like the concept of the werewolf was
also kind of cross-pollinated with
nowadays what we would call a serial
killer like if like there was a bunch of
[__] up murders happening somewhere
and people said like well a human
couldn't possibly be doing this so it
has to be some kind of Beast and then
that would you know and then it would
follow that this is a person that can
like turn into a beast and it's doing
all of this kind of [__] up [__] so
there's that kind of uh [__] too but I
kind of feel like where people that got
that turned into werewolves it was
usually through
bad behavior and it was usually
something that
um
they were it was usually like some kind
of sexual bad behavior you know what I
mean like they were really promiscuous
or they were really
or they were rapists or something like
that
um they would get accused of being
werewolves because werewolves were seen
as like these hypersexual
over like overtly masculine like I said
until very recent times I kind of feel
like almost all werewolf stories were
yeah
but there were some there were some
serial killers that thought back in
there that's what that's what I was just
talking about 1900s that thought they
were werewolves
that's what I was just talking about
yeah you're talking about he was like a
[__]
he was out there
in the middle of nowhere with his sister
that they grew up together remember that
they had all the kids together and he
was going out killing women on the
countryside and eating parts of them he
thought he was a werewolf yeah but he
wasn't though but
they killed him all on the wheel though
I think he even killed the children on
the wheel didn't they yeah yeah
it's weird
be it broken on the wheels I mean they
didn't play it back then even if you
were just kind of like associated with
if somebody just like whispered demon in
your direction they're like well that's
the thumb screws for you who's that dude
and his sister though were I think
they'd probably fall under the category
of being feral
the thing about it I don't know anybody
except that old man that raised him
because what I was just talking about in
the sense that wolf like werewolves and
serial killers were almost kind of like
because like I said they didn't really
have a concept of serial killers back
then in the way that we do now yeah so
that might have kind of like played into
the werewolf thing too but I kind of
feel like
um
you can't really take anything because
like the the case of Peter stump who you
know confessed to being a werewolf and
doing all this Witchcraft and stuff like
that but he confessed all that stuff
under torture so I kind of feel like all
of this kind of splashy
[__] up [__] that all these people
said that they did back in those old
days it's like yeah but were you pulling
their toenails out at the time that they
said because people will say anything to
like avoid that because I was talking
about didn't do that under torture he
confessed openly yeah that must be a
different dude he's a different guy
said he and his sister were raised by an
old man out in an AB Cottage
remember that guy remember that case
1400s
he didn't remember who his parents were
but he and his sister were raised by an
old man who did read the Bible to him
and did something then he died
and he died when they were like 10. and
then they raised each other
outed out in that little cottage out in
the middle of nowhere they had kids
together by the time he was about 17 or
18 I think he was going around killing
people because he thought he was a
werewolf
they kept finding half dead women that
were girls they were mauled
I could see it had bite marks all over
and partly eaten
well like I said down to him and he said
he was a werewolf and told his whole
life story to him and then they killed
him and his sister and their children
it broke him on the Wheel
but like I said that is an actual mental
illness which is actually called
lycanthropy where people don't actually
transform into wolves but they think
that they do yeah they do genuinely
think that they do and they go out and
do Wolfie [__]
but they don't realize that they're not
actually turning into words you know
it's like it's a delusion
so um here's another interesting and I'm
not really sure what the origin of this
was but there's a lot of werewolf
stories particularly coming out of
Germany in that kind of that region
where people
um are werewolves and they can become
werewolves pretty much wherever they
want because they have like a magic this
is gonna sound stupid
um a magic belt essentially or like a
magic piece of clothing it's usually a
belt or like a little it's usually made
out of wolf skin or fur or something
like that and they can put it on and
then they'll turn into a werewolf
problem is that if you
um destroy the belt while they're a wolf
then they can't change back to a person
so there's like a bunch of folk tales
particularly coming out of Germany where
you know there's we're almost there like
hey I'm gonna be a werewolf today so
they put their special werewolf belt on
and they go around and run out and kill
deer or whatever and then somebody is
like he he and then like they take their
belt away and like [__] destroy it so
you can't Dennis Mickey is mentioning
Berserkers I was just actually I that I
was actually that was my next paragraph
they were like wolf Clans
if you watch that movie what was that uh
oblith
what was that story about what was it
called uh the endorsement yeah a great
movie yeah I love that movie great movie
it's where Hamlet was based on
Shakespeare's Hamlet was based on the
story
and Prince ablith was a was a Berserker
a bizarre
it's called bezart
they were kind of like which they did
woes but then the Bears too yeah any
kind of where like I said any kind of
like big like Predator because they were
Warrior Cults they'd take a bunch of
[__] drugs and [__] start chanting
and working themselves up into a frenzy
a bunch of Rites of Passage that they
did and then after that they did they
were ended up they kind of became packs
of mercenaries that Vikings would use as
like shock troops
because it was probably pretty scary
seeing like a whole bunch of big Burly
dudes running at you and [__] wolf
and bear skins yeah they were nude
mostly yeah they yeah [__] animal
heads and a lot of times they would like
paint their skin black and like all of a
sudden they wanted to look like as
terrifying as possible
because it was like psychological
warfare yeah they didn't care if they
got killed or not they were totally
disregarded their own safety yeah robots
talked about them even though they
weren't talking about that those
particular ones the Romans said that
there were a lot of people of the
Germanic tribes that were like that they
would attack you where they were nude
and animal costumes that they were
fierce
they use large steel swords Hand Forged
steel swords this is in time when the
Roman armies just used bronze still you
know
the the so-called barbarians were not
primitive they just weren't Romans
the Romans called them barbarians but
they were well of course they were going
to call them that yeah they had good
weapons technology
they can make steel
[Music]
we also had saddles on horses with
stirrups Romans didn't have that it was
just wild they were just more fierce
they were dubbed though Mr 88 said Trick
or Treat the movie has a whole pride of
female werewolves yeah that's right but
like I said female werewolves is a
pretty modern
construction I think there were like a
couple of them like sprinkled in the
ancient stories but like 99 of the old
werewolf stories there was always men
that's a sexy concept though
like you're a regular dude these women
could have come but they're gonna [__]
you you know you don't have a choice now
I have heard of like sorts like I said
there's a lot of it better be hot
there's a lot there's a lot of crossover
between werewolfury and Witchcraft yeah
because they were kind of seen I know
they weren't seen as the same thing but
werewolfury was considered like one
thing that like witches yeah would do
you know I mean that was something that
you could get accused of at witch trials
there were werewolf trials as well
people accused of being werewolves and
also other kind of Witchcraft but I do
kind of feel like werewolves were
genuinely seen as a very masculine type
of monster I do kind of feel like
witches
because you did get some cases of like
witches uh like folklore about which is
shape-shifting but I feel like they
didn't usually shapeshift female witches
didn't usually shape-shift into wolves
though did they
no I kind of feel like they
shape-shifted into like other animals
like I said I read like an old story a
long time ago about a woman that was a
witch but she shape-shifted into a big
cat yeah cats cats are seen as like more
feminine I guess cats rabbits foxes
things like that that yeah that kind of
[__] I kind of because they're smaller
they're still Predators but they're not
as badass as wolves I guess I don't know
what it is but yeah so
is weird because I do kind of feel like
and I it's now we're getting back to
serial killers again but I do kind of
feel a lot of serial killers and I think
even BTK said this outright because he
started
strangling cats when he was a kid which
should have just like snuffed him out
right then I mean just just let's save
everyone in some trouble but um
because people with that mentality
serial killers
they tend to see cats as more feminine
animals for whatever reason
well they scream like women
that's what they said that's yeah he did
say that yeah but I don't know if that's
entirely it though
I do kind of feel like and I feel like
this is it's it's you know it's not like
it used to be but I do kind of feel like
people have a sense of
wolves and dogs as more masculine
animals even though obviously wolves and
dogs can be male or female but they
always think of cats as like more
feminine animals
for whatever reason and [__] man even
cat people the Val Luton movie from the
40s that had a Serbian woman Irina
turning into a panther so she was a
werewolf but she was a were Panther
whenever she got sexually aroused she
turned into a wear Panther that came out
in the 40s you guys they didn't like
they danced around it but you could like
pretty much it gastroent lesbianism too
in that movie they did a good movie that
honestly I'm gonna argue I think that
was the one of the best if not the best
horror movies great class I really
really like that movie I liked all of
Val Newton's movies but cat people I
think is my favorite
but yeah so so again you have the
werewolf thing she's a you know a
werewolf but she turns into a panther
she turns into a cat
so I kind of feel like that's
interesting that it's like this whole
male female Dynamic and there's like the
more I looked into the history I'm just
like yeah pretty much all the old
werewolf stories it's all dudes like
almost all dudes so the funny thing
about it is that so they have a thing so
there's a whole sub-genre of werewolf
stories where demons have a special
werewolf belt and I guess they can just
put it on whenever they want a werewolf
out right there's like I'm gonna go have
some werewolf times and they should go
out in the woods and they just put the
belt on so they can do whatever they
want to but then there's another
sub-genre of stories where the dudes and
this is a pretty common story too
where the dudes can also turn into
werewolves whenever they want but they
have to go out in the woods they have to
take all their clothes off and they're
like okay I'm gonna wolf out now but the
thing about it is that if they can't get
back to their clothes because here's
another common thing they take off all
their clothes they go to the woods when
they want a wolf out they take off all
their clothes the clothes turn into
stone for reasons
um and then they'll pee around them yeah
like to keep people away I'm guessing to
keep you from taking them and then they
run up yeah and then they run off and
like do their werewolfury business and
then they come out and then the
magically the the clothes magically turn
back into clothes again and they put
them back on and they're just normal so
there's a bunch of different stories
probably the most famous of these
is um what's it called it's called Uh
biscala vet bisclovay biscalibrate
something like that so it's like this
long poem like a love poem
and it's a similar story stat where it's
a dude and he's a werewolf and he goes
out and his wife who's [__] around on
him with some other chode and she finds
out he's a werewolf because they follow
him one day and so they go out in the
woods and they see him do the whole
ritual he takes off the clothes he pees
around him the clothes turn into stone
bloody blah and then he runs off and
beats a werewolf and she's like oh hmm
this is this is an opportunity so she
decides her and her boyfriend are gonna
[__] him over so they take his clothes
away so he can't turn back into a human
you know what I mean but it ends up so
he stays a wolf
but then there's this whole thing where
it's like he like the king comes out in
the woods and like he goes up to him as
a wolf and he's just like and the king
is his buddy so he's like oh hey it's
you and he like licks his face or
something like that so the king like
recognizes him so he ends up
figuring out that like the wife [__]
him over and it's like this whole thing
so I think like the wife and the lover
get killed or something like that but
it's like there's a whole
small subgenre of folklore where dudes
who are werewolves like their wives [__]
them over by taking their clothes away
so they can't turn back into human again
so it's like
is this [__] women again taking your
clothes away so you have to stay a wolf
forever you can't just run around be a
wolf you have to yeah so there's like a
bunch of that
so like I said the whole thing about
getting bit by a wolf and that turns you
into a werewolf I'm pretty sure
that's a very very modern idea and I
think the whole full moon thing is a
pretty modern idea too that might have
come from the universal movie
or 1941.
um as did the whole Silver Bullet thing
now I will concede that for whatever
reason
silver has always been seen as uh
effective against lots of supernatural
creatures like I said not just
werewolves but vampires and stuff too
but specifically a silver bullet I think
that's like a pretty modern that might
be from the 1941 movie I don't know if
there was an earlier reference to it
that came from that but just like
everything else all the a lot of the
stuff that we know about werewolves is
like pretty much from the movies like
not so much from
the thing and I think too
The Wolf Man from 1941 might have been
the first time that you saw I don't know
about the first time but the first time
like the first kind of big cultural
thing where it was like a half man half
wolf because he was like still a dude
but he just had like a wolf face and
they probably just did that because that
was
cheaper
um it's you know cheaper than like doing
the whole wolf transforming thing like
they did later on because I kind of feel
like in a lot of the werewolf stories
like where you see a werewolf movie
nowadays and you want to see the
transformation scene right that's kind
of like the big centerpiece of any like
look at American Werewolf in London or
anything or the howling or um or
anything like that you want to see
the person changing into a wolf
but I kind of feel like that wasn't as
important back in the old days you know
what I'm saying like they were just
concerned about yeah the dude turned
into a wolf it was like magical or
whatever but they didn't really like
focus on it it was kind of more it is
most of the fact that's well that's what
I'm saying and I kind of feel like the
whole man wolf hybrid came about almost
kind of like out of necessity because
back in the 1940s when they made the
Wolfman movie
they didn't have the effects to you know
they just had to do everything through
dissolves and so it was mostly just his
face and His Hands they just like put
fur on his hand and stuff like that so
like I said it was cheaper
you know and it's easier to just make
him look like you know 99 like a dude
but just like with a wolfy face and
hands
much easier than doing what they did in
American Werewolf in London where they
actually showed him turning into a wolf
and it like looking super painful and
everything which still looks good I
think like I don't know if
if that's just because I'm old like I
don't know if
no most people think that the old
practical effects was the way to go I
mean I still I that looks really good I
still think that looks really good you
know what I mean that transformation I
think that's probably still the best
transformation because nowadays they
just do it with CGI and that always
looks like ass
but that was all done that was all done
with practical effects that was all done
with bladders and like that they put
under the skin and like all this other
kind of stuff like under fake skin and
it looks fantastic I think I just saw
that movie again like a year ago and I
still think it looks good and like I
said I don't know if that's just because
I'm old or what but that's there's that
whole thing but yeah I kind of feel like
the more modern conception and this
comes from the Universal movies as well
is that you kind of have
because in The Wolf Man Larry Talbot
the main character you know he's a nice
guy he's a sympathetic protagonist he
gets bitten by a wolf like no fault of
his own and ends up becoming a werewolf
and it's this big like existential
crisis because like oh now I'm turning
into a monster like I mean I can't help
it you know what I mean whereas prior to
that I kind of feel like
you were either yeah it was a curse like
early but then like there was a whole
thing through the medieval period where
you could just like choose to be a
werewolf like it's like I'm gonna go let
off some steam or whatever so it was
like a whole different thing but it's
like then it kind of went back in the
direction of you know
you just got bit by a wolf and it
happened in American Werewolf in London
too like they were just out hiking and
like the one dude got killed and then
like the other dude didn't get killed he
got bit but then he started turning into
werewolf and then he had like this whole
like [__] crisis about it because
it's like now you're turning into a
werewolf and you're killing
people
um you know you're killing innocent
people and you're not being aware of it
so it's kind of like a curse in that way
too but I kind of feel like now like in
later media
um you kind of see more of a thing where
people can choose to be a werewolf
because after the Wolfman came out I
kind of feel like there were several
decades where
it just happened during the full moon
whether you wanted it to or not and
Ginger Snaps did that too
but I feel like nowadays it's kind of
more like oh I can just wolf out
whenever I want a wolf out or I wolf out
when I get mad or something like that so
it's my so it's much more
flexible I guess like less like a curse
and more like oh well just like a thing
I do or a thing that happens when my
emotions get the best of me or [__] like
that you know what I mean which I don't
know it's just kind of interesting the
way that
mythology like changes over time is what
I'm saying
so wait a minute what time is it oh [__]
it's getting really really late should
we like wrap this up probably yeah go
ahead I kind of feel like right I mean
covered it I mean we pretty much covered
it I didn't have like much more to cover
and I feel like it's getting really late
and I have to like go to sleep soon yeah
if you really want to experience being a
werewolf go ahead and shoot up a bunch
of trend below you'd be like me yeah
let's talk about it somebody sent me a
message earlier yeah somebody sent me a
message earlier yeah on it or it was a
comment on one of our Side Tracks videos
and said that we should do a trend
stories video yeah we can do trans
stories and I mean
it is kind of like it's like being a
werewolf kinda I even [__] after
going through my Trend ordeal five
months being on Trend I even got like
werewolf Motif Viking yeah Viking
werewolf Motif jewelry
so yeah I was a werewolf I was werewolf
for [__] three months
two months out of that five months
fight everybody you want to [__]
everybody you want to kill everybody
it's just [__] bizarre now not
everybody on Trend does that
but you should it tends to be like that
some guys could take it and they
they can resist it pretty well
a lot of guys just take it it [__] them
up they love it like my friend in gay
porn like I'll tell you about Daniel
[__] he he loves trend
but he's gonna [__] some twinks all
right and he's gonna try to make money
with that somehow he's just well I mean
that's his kind of his job though yeah
that's okay yeah but I'm just saying
[__] huge bodybuilder who [__] the
wings
and he's mean about it
but that's what they're paying him
that's what he does he's a werewolf
but no I went to the werewolf thing
it calls me I want to go back to it but
it's just uh well because eventually
somebody will kill you and what I told
him is that you know
the the hell of it is is that you
damn being on it yeah or having a great
time yeah meanwhile everybody else
around you is having a horrible
miserable time yeah so
I'm walking on eggshells yeah yeah I
mean and that's what I told you later
like I didn't want to tell you at the
time because you've already shot me in
the face but you know what I mean
my hands or something because that's
what I mean you're very fast and you're
very strong on it you're very volatile
and you're very animalistic on that [__]
the one for one
milligram per milligram trend is five
times more powerful than testosterone
and you're taking quite a bit of it
and whenever I see these werewolf movies
you know like [__] you know what's
his name Jack Nicholson with [__]
wolf
I was like yeah that's that's it that's
trend
Trent is also Dr Jekyll Mr Hyde though
Mr Hyde that's also yeah it's also the
Goblin [__] where Osborne
[__] uh takes his [__] combat what
was called what was called combat
[__] uh
performance enhancing
steroids and yeah
that's that's what that shit's like I
don't recommend a trend
I won't be going back to that you take
it and you like just as much as you want
to yeah you take it you like it you
start taking more of it but I but I will
have to like go stay in a hotel yeah and
you're like well they say you're only
supposed to take this for about [__]
10 weeks but you know I feel good I'm
gonna continue to take it I'm gonna
continue to take it then five months
later you're still on it you're
you're evil
basically yeah
so
and doing all this [__] kind of made me
think you know are these serial killers
are they maybe there's something wrong
with their endocrine systems are they
making certain kinds of things that are
like testosterone I mean it's possible
not quite
because tread is a 19 North testosterone
uh [__] uh
it it's a mother compound it's 19 North
testosterone
which is like normal testosterone it's
just that one of the carbon one of the
carbon atoms is moved to another
position in there it's real close to
testosterone
chemically but not in its effects so it
makes you wonder if some of these
[__] weird-ass serial killers
are mutants and they're just making
another context well they gotta have
something wrong with that there's a kind
of makes something wrong with because
I've told you before it's like and we're
not saying because I know that there
have been some people that had like
relatively quote unquote normal
upbrings and stuff like that and they
did turn out to be serial killers
um and then you have people that might
have been normal otherwise but then they
endured like horrific abuse and that
turned them into serial killers but I
kind of feel like
serial killers would be a lot more
common if there wasn't some kind of
biological biological element that had
to be cross-bred with environmental
illness yeah it has to be like a perfect
storm yeah that's what I think it is
because otherwise it would be a lot more
common because there's a lot of guys
there's a lot of guys that go through
that [__] why aren't they serial killers
man that's what I'm saying grab those
serial killers and I do a blood test on
that and look at their testosterone
the not only the qualities of it but I
look at that [__] under electron
microscope is is their version of
testosterone closer to Trend it might be
Tran will make you evil
yeah you said all it feels like a crazy
[__] oh yeah it feels great and then
well and like I said and that was the
frustrating thing about it is that you
thought you were fine yeah but you were
like saying just insane stuff yeah but
like you couldn't like tell I couldn't
tell you that you were saying insane
stuff because you wouldn't believe me no
because it seemed normal at the time
right but it absolutely was not if you
look at you look at a tread look at it
like like look at tread chemically and
you look at [__] testosterone side by
side they look almost exactly the same
but the effects are very different I've
taken all
all the Esters of [__] testosterone
I've taken most of the different kinds
of [__] steroids that are based on
testosterone DHT derivatives
testosterone derivatives [__] 19 Nor
testosterone derivatives I've taken most
of all the major ones
there's nothing like trend
tread below is [__] Wicked Victor
said I want to do train and [__] twinks
it'll make you a homosexual rapist I
mean as long as other people aren't
around you because like I said it's very
very fun for the person taking it yeah
I'm sure but not so fun for everyone
else you don't you don't uh
be honest towards women you know what I
mean you're real simply towards women
[__] recipient protective but you
just wanted to kill men
especially weak men we make weak men you
wanted to attack and kill
like they didn't have a right to exist
some bizarre [__] man bizarre well and
you were also having like really really
bad like
um what should I call it delusions of
grandeur yeah yeah you think you're a
God
yeah and actually I think you said
exactly that yeah at some point yeah
yeah
you were kind of I'm just like are you
kidding or no you're not you weren't
kidding and I was like well you saw me
in a fight two or three I'm in trouble I
would go to the nightclub and if dude's
[__] violated you know thank you
Victor we went to the nightclub [__]
dudes grabbed her ass I [__] jumped
on that dude [__] grabbed him by the
[__] throw you'll fight four or five
guys and these are six Footers I'm
[__] five six
and I'll jump on three or four or five
six foot guys and try to fight them and
drive them off
yeah
and Daniel was like oh yeah I was
telling Daniel about he goes oh yeah you
can beat anybody's ass when you're on
that when you're your size and then he's
like you should come out to the club
with me we'll get we'll get jacked on
tread and we'll fight the whole club and
then we'll fight the cops when they show
up and I'm like and then you'll get shot
and I'm like yeah that sounds good that
sounds good that's what I mean like
stupid [__] like that sounds good too
I'm like and I'm like hold on let me get
shot
leaving me alone leaving leaving Pookie
and Dakota's orphans yeah well it's it's
kind of a bloodlust type thing
but look everyone off that [__] it took
me about a month or so to get back to
normal yeah here's the thing it's like I
I don't know like I you know I wouldn't
presume to speak for anybody else
because I know I'm like a weirdo and
everything but it's just kind of like
look I'm not denying
that I'm not out sometimes and don't
want to pull someone's head off I do
yeah I think everybody feels like that
like especially if you're in a certain
kind of mood and like people are just
being a certain kind of way and you're
just like man if I could kill this
[__] right now and get away with it I
absolutely would and like I've thought
about it lots of times but it's like and
I think most people are like that I
don't I don't know if that's me
projecting but it's like I kind of feel
like most people yeah most people have
anger yeah yeah I mean I do too I get it
yeah but I just kind of feel like
I mean I'd have to be really really
drunk before I would even consider
because I understand that there are
consequences yeah and I'm just kind of
like I don't want to ruin my whole
[__] life yeah just because this one
person is doing something really
annoying right now you know what I mean
it's like I'd like to kill them if I
could get away with it maybe I would but
I know I'm not gonna when they're
talking about when they're talking about
werewolf stories embracing the animal
side of yourself the things like [__]
animal passions and bloodlust and the
that's tread
yeah it's very much for most people
that's what I am that's what I meant
when I said that I feel like there's
less explanation yeah necessary for
werewolf myths because everybody can
understand because we are animals as
well so we still have a lot of those I
don't know if I'd necessarily even call
them out ofistic because they're still
present so but you still have a lot of
those animalistic urges yeah everybody
has those to greater or lesser degrees
so it's like so I understand that people
have fantasies about just you know
throwing off the constrictors of
constrictions of society or whatever I
mean that was the same thing that Jekyll
and Hyde well I mean Jekyll and Hyde is
essentially a werewolf story is what
that is yeah
um because it's somebody that's like oh
he's sick of all this uptight Victorian
society [__] and he just wants to go
around and like Club people with his
Cane and [__] like now I think I think
uh Jacqueline Hyde originally was about
cocaine
that too I think originally but there
are newer versions of Jekyll and Hyde
that came out like 90s 80s and 90s when
he was dealing with a powerful pheromone
and a pheromone is like a hormone and
hormones are testosterone
steroids steroids are modified hormones
and once again they're talking about
Trend Trend will turn you into [__]
[__] Mr Hyde
yeah the same with the Goblin
all these little [__] stories that DC
and the Marvels there was always
inspired by something that really
existed
well you got to get ideas you know I'm a
writer too you get ideas yeah somewhere
and you usually get ideas from real [__]
yeah the goblin I mean I always did the
Goblin and uh Mr Hyde
was based upon the effects of [__]
Roid Rage basically yeah that's what
kind of what they're talking about even
though
trend is not rage
you never really get like a rage per se
it's it's just a seething [__]
animalistic [__]
urges you know what I mean you kind of
see the animal King you kind of seemed
like
um
what's that animal that's pissed off all
the time a wolverine a wolverine yeah
right like a wolverine you were just
like low-key pissed off all the time
like
yeah yeah like you're always like that
yeah which like I said I get it because
I'm kind of like that too but I'm like
that naturally I don't even eat anything
and then like somebody does something to
you yeah wow and it's instant you don't
think about it you just do it instantly
Trent is in charge not really you see
honestly it's good that I don't take
that or that I don't have that because I
feel like that quite a bit too yeah
um but I also have like the other side
of me that's just kind of like don't
ruin your whole life Jenny it's like you
could kill this person I know you want
to but it's like you better not well I
ate a couple of really big shrimp
bologna sandwiches and I've had enough I
understand what it does I don't want to
go back down that path there's so many
other compounds there like I said you
jump back on that I'm moving to a hotel
for a few months I'm not there's so many
other ones that are just that can do
just as much for you and they don't have
those weird side effects
it was originally made for humans sure
and Below but then after they saw what
that kind of did to you they said no
that's that's like no livestock only not
really safe for humans yeah they give it
to cows and cows well and some people
that have taken it have legit like
murdered people yeah that guy that
[__] attacked that cop with a hatchet
just for no reason and it got shot up
Trent the dude who jumped who who
thought that those people living in that
house had abducted a girl
he killed the the wife and the mama
it has to work see that's what I mean
and it's like you never know like [__]
there's a girl in there you could have
gone and killed our [__] neighbors
nah I don't know that dude must have
been on a much more of the [__]
or had a certain weakness to it
I mean I knew I was [__] up but I
mean can she I mean to be honest and
like I mean this with all love and
respect but you're kind of a dick before
so it's like so then on all that stuff
it's like it was like Amplified like a
thousand times yeah and I was like holy
crap you really do not need that yeah
John says Jenny I would recommend
someone came here and said I was
terrifying and that was after you'd
already been off of it for a little
while a couple weeks and I was like yeah
and I told her later on I've been off it
for a week yeah and I was just like two
months and I was like oh you should have
been here a little while back yeah you'd
have been even more scared you've been
hiding under the [__] table yeah like
I was I was just like in here yeah but I
wasn't violent towards no but I knew
it's just well no but the thing about it
was that you were acting so erratically
that there was no way that we could know
what I was gonna do next what you were
gonna do next that's what I mean that's
what's scary about it is that you don't
like yeah you can say that now but it's
like at the time I had no like you were
acting so crazy that I was just kind of
like well [__] Anything Could Happen
yeah you know what I mean so it was like
that right internally I was being
internally I was very
um
sentimental
and simpy and but I didn't see I didn't
get any of that though none of that was
coming out externally internally I was
real simpy and sentimental and
overprotective
and trying to protect women and that I
cared about you know so you're very much
like but and to do this you have to
attack men which is that so that's and
then like not saying I wouldn't like we
attack men too I do they're like weak
men are more disgusting so you want to
attack them first and then strong men
are a threat so we have to attack that
you're very much like something out of
the animal kingdom you're not thinking
about it it's just you're just doing it
I just want to attack [__]
whether they're men or women everybody I
did attack
was an [__] Jenny contest yeah I will
give you that like you didn't really
like it well not well not that I know of
no I mean you might have gone out when I
was not here and done some [__] that I
don't know about no I wasn't but you had
to be bad if you were bad I was gonna
attack you and like so yeah so like in
some ways I didn't feel too bad cause
I'm like yeah I'd ever be in a dick they
probably yeah you know what I mean
because some people I mean I'm not a big
advocate of violence but some people
really do need to be punched in the
mouth
but I mean I don't know if they'll learn
anything but but I will say that I loved
it it felt great
and I kind of miss it but I know that
that's that's not the right way to be
you put that um seriously you take that
[__] again I'm gonna like strap you to
the bed
yeah you know what I mean like they do
like they used to do in the old-timey
like insane as Islands yeah I'm gonna
strap you down for you Jim Bros who know
what I'm talking about with the
trampoloni sandwiches don't [__] with
Trent just
take test and NPP NPP is real close or
deca deca's good I'm on Deca right now
test and deca am I on that now you're on
Deca I am also on Deck very small amount
Decca derably it's very close to Trend I
don't feel anything it doesn't have any
of those weird mental side effects
I never feel any different yeah I always
feel pretty much the same yeah
well well that goes back to what you
were saying earlier where I must be one
of those you don't respond weak
responders kind of a weak responder yeah
well like I said I'll take it I'm not I
know you say that like it's about but
you do respond do you have I do but not
the way that other people do your shape
has changed for the better but like I
said it's not like dramatic no
but I've been on it for months now I
have that with everything whether it's
illness or medicine or anything like
that like everything is just kind of
like meh I'm just kind of very just Jen
did about a month and a half on NPP now
she's on Deca which are very similar
yeah and like I said he always asked me
like because he tries to like Monitor
and he's just like will you feel any
different I'm like nope yeah yeah I
never feel anything and she's doing like
between 50 and 100 a week
it's a long Ester it uh D'Angelo
19 North I always feel pretty much the
same here and for postmenopausal women
that's what they want to be on because
this prevents osteoporosis and keeps
their figures looking good
yeah I mean that's good like I have
noticed a difference but it's not like
super dramatic you know what I mean I
don't feel any different the thing about
tread is that tread really didn't make
that much it was more about shape I
didn't gain a lot of size but I did get
a better shape
but I don't think it was worth the
mental side effects and I think no it
definitely was NPP did about the same
thing
yeah honestly I didn't really see that
that it made that much more of a
difference than it would
Europe be worth it because it made you
act like a crazy person
NPP and [__] decadarabalin they're
all the same 19 North testosterone types
and just different Esters of them you
want to go with MPP for if you want
short Ester which is fast acting or you
want to go Deca for like a longer
longer acting
steroid that's in the background just
kind of working slowly you know uh real
good for HRT or hormone replacement
therapy you mix it up with the right
proportions of test of testosterone and
inject it and it's it's good especially
if you're over 40
good they're not good on young people
you know but they're real good on older
people
all of them
steroids and young people don't really
mix
because young people have
well-functioning endocrine systems you
have enough hormones there where you can
do well but when you get older those
hormones shut down so you got to replace
it with something
yeah I mean I wouldn't really advise
getting into that [__] until you get
older
e30s because when you're young you don't
need it you don't need as much you don't
need it no
you just try to get about 35 37 that's
when you start thinking about
replacement
John said Jenny I would recommend you
listen to night of the wolf it's an
old-fashioned radio drama with Vincent
Price and it's about Vincent Price going
to find his son who is turned into a
werewolf and he said it's on YouTube
it's great I will actually yeah I will
actually definitely listen to that maybe
I can listen to my car in the morning
now that I'm thinking about it if it's
on YouTube I'll just put it on my car
stereo Jeff you are gives another two
dollars thank you very much oh thank you
thank you thank you thank you
Ben says all things in moderation
yeah no not at all things I will be
tread in moderation
yeah some things you should probably
just not do any of but um you know I'm
not going to do any Flocka or yeah or
anything like that but you know what I
mean but like most things most things in
moderation let's let's put it that way
alcohol in moderation ish uh because we
do like to drink a lot yeah uh some
other drugs in moderation
fattening foods in moderation
but you know some things probably no
and then Ben said I'm not a violent
person but yeah well
I mean there's some situations where
like I said that's not the only way out
of the situation is but yeah yeah and
you know I'm not gonna lie and usually
like the drunker I get like sometimes
I'm like man that person really needs to
be like [__] kicked in the team right
now
but like I said I don't know if they
would learn anything so I don't know how
effective it would be but what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do all right
so I really have to go to bed yeah
I do I have to get up at five in the
morning
um but yeah hopefully you guys enjoyed
the show uh you know we kind of mostly
talked about vampires but we talked
about werewolves and [__] too we mostly
stayed on topic right I feel like yeah
you know I think it's okay show we got
paid for it yeah okay that's always good
so we'll be back on Friday night for the
Sidetrack show and I don't think we're
going anywhere this Friday so we can
just feel free to sit here and drink and
talk to our hearts content
you better not be you'll be better by
then that's two days away
um but yeah so hopefully you guys can
join us for that so remember to
like and comment and all that other kind
of stuff and we will see you guys again
on Friday night good night